on book tv
next in depth with studs turkle
[Music]
studs turkle is an interviewer actor
broadcaster and the author of 13 books
he's our guest today on in depth for the
next three hours your phone calls in a
conversation with studs turkle on his
life and books from giants of jazz and
hard times to the spectator and my
american dream
we'll look at the events of the last
century through the eyes of this chicago
writer and the people he's met along the
way
stud sterkle thanks for being with us
your books are about people
how many have you interviewed over the
years oh god how many interviews
thousands
about
let's say
remember i was on a radio program in
chicago for 45 years a classical music
station fine art station 45 years five
days a week and it was eclectic
invite all sorts of people writers
actors burglars all sorts of people
neighborhood activists
peace people
all sorts uh
thousands so i've given the reels
they were tapes and i've given them to
the chicago historical society so now i
work for the chicago historical so they
call me
god forgive me a distinguished fellow
and so the thousands of tapes
i'd say nine ten thousand including
people of the books cited in the radio
broadcast
in a tony parker's book about you you're
quoted as saying i've given voice to the
voices of those we never hear yeah tony
parker was a remarkable man died
recently uh he did what i do or i did
what
did what he did when he was alive in
london interviewing the non-celebrated
people see
celebrities the word celebrity has no
meaning to me
einstein is celebrated that's true so is
joshua gabor you see
it
there's no meaning to the word celebrity
and no point interviewing them they are
interviewed and we know what they say
so the ordinary people so-called the
word i dislike ordinary because ordinary
people using quotes
are capable of extraordinary things i
found out whether book about the
depression or world war ii or the daily
work or a matter of race a matter of
aging
and so in a sense
voice to the voiceless
my model i guess was a was a
contemporary of charles dickens his name
was charles uh his name was henry mayhew
henry mayhew was was a prototype i'm
told
of micawber mccobber's a lot like me
slovenly and waiting for something to
turn up and this guy
captured the voices of people who were
like well-behaved children seen but
never heard the chimney sweep the
seamstress the chamber made
and middle class england was astonished
at what he found out so he's sort of my
guide in a way
when alex haley wrote roots
the first thing he went to do is to
visit the land of his forebears gambian
west africa and speak to oral historians
the cold griots
oral history has long long preceded the
feather panel gutenberg
god help us the computer you see so
what i'm doing is ancient except that i
have a tape recorder
only one other guy used a tape recorder
was enamored aside from me and that was
richard nixon
so i described nixon to myself as
neo-cartesians
that is i tape therefore i am
and so i hope our purposes are somewhat
different but an event any event that's
what i do
try to give voice i suppose to
romanticize it
not that much to the voiceless that's
all
where do you write
what's that where do you write
well i write and i don't write i do a
combination i improvise in my house
there's a typewriter which is far as
i'll go no computer it's electric
typewriter which is a tremendous advance
for me
most my letters are written longhand
because i hunt and peck
but you mentioned
a computer to me is that what you said
no i'm i'm sort of a luddite no i
believe in the refrigerator because
where else can can i freeze my martini
glass you see so so i do believe in
certain things yeah
now i believe in advances i'm also an
ungrateful wretch i was saved by
technology i had a quintuple bypass
about four years ago
five years ago or not for that i'd be
dead and here i am condemning technology
i have a tape see now and then i may as
people will call in i'm going to ask
steve my colleague to repeat the
question because
hearing i have a hearing aid this is
state of the art it's called doesn't do
any good so i'm a bionic matter is not
quite
informed yet we've got a ifb and we have
speakers so hopefully
this is an experiment i realize they're
going to call it
and so we're flying without a net
how did somebody born lewis get the name
studs i i will
i wish it were what you think it was
unfortunately it wasn't you know uh the
name i loved studs lonergan i was named
louis l-u-i-s
and stud lining a novel by james t
farrell back in the 30s about a chicago
guy william studlanigan whose life was
wasted and i was taken with that trilogy
of books but then it got me in trouble
once when i did working
the book working
there was a fireman in the book who's
wonderful tommy gates tommy patrick and
he uses
tony uh soprano language and talking
in a very colorful idioms
you know
randy idioms
and so
this is a letter i got from a librarian
in georgia she missed the book author
lunch in which i appeared
the life of a librarian is not too
exciting but have its pecan moments such
as when you wrote the book working
one of my people working for me
was
a spy that is to see i had no dirty
books he was a devotee of jerry falwell
and donald wildman and looked for dirty
words
and he said to me once miss cooper i
think her name was sylvia cooper miss
cooper a request has come for a book i
think you're getting that i think i said
to the subscriber we don't carry
pornographic literature and she said
what's the name of the book i believe
it's called working studs by turkle
and that's when i knew i had a
bestseller well that's the only time it
got me in trouble
born in new york born new york came at
the age of eight with my folks my father
was ill
wonderful trailer
and uh
a well-off brother lent us some money to
lease the rooming house
and then later on my father tried to run
a hotel ailing hard or not and so the
rooming house and the hotel were really
my
my universities i wanted chicago law
school god help me i don't know why i
did
three most bleak years of my life i
dreamed of clarence darrow and woke up
to antonin scalia you know so what are
you going to do
why why did you like law school what's
that why didn't i cut out for
see i yeah i dreamed of clarence darrow
the partnership corporations it drove me
crazy
so i one thing or another my life was an
accretion of accidents the wpa writers
project the new deal was there had a
civil civic
civil servant for a time in washington
making 1260 a year that's the second
lowest caf2
counting baby bonds and went nuts became
an actor by accident i became a gangster
a chicago gangster in radio soap operas
chicago was the home of many so i was
they all were the same all the soap
operas were the same
guiding light was about a minister woman
of whites about a nurse the same script
i always got a job but i was losing this
i was getting killed no tenure
you know many jobs lousy tenure like
radical college professor you know and
as a result of which uh
one thing led do another i became a disc
jockey before the word disc jockey was
used to love jazz
and that was eclectic i'd play classical
jazz take off on operas i do the
libretto of an opera in the argo of a
racetrack tout long shot sylvester
carmen about a tomato loves not too
wisely but too often you know and then i
play an aria though a 1918 aria by a
carmen of that time conchita superior
or one of those early singers singing in
the habanera see mix things up west end
blues louis armstrong follows woody
guthrie's dust bowl balance it was that
kind of program then became a
commentator one thing led to another
and then finally i wound up on this
radio station interviewing people it was
all accidental
and a woman called one day and said you
should do this more often one
interview people i hadn't caught an
interview with conversations why because
it seems though i'm eavesdropping to an
actual conversation in contrast to what
i hear otherwise and so
and some of my interviews appeared in
in magazine of the station and my
publisher andre schifrin now the new
press called me one day and suggested an
idea of her a book and that's how it
began
what was stud's place
stud's place was
how can i describe it it was a radio
program about a neighborhood restaurant
run by me
myself studs my name who's adult sort of
okay but
and there's a waitress wonderful actress
named beverly younger played the
waitress
and there was a handyman self-educated
like old-time wobblies you know winstrot
he was a singer by the way a very good
leader singer so he played this and chet
roble played the piano
bluesy kind of guy so without realizing
the four aspects of american life
in these four people
and people actually thought there was a
stud's place
and 20 years after it's dropped down
then some old one would say to me
this meaning i know what you meant what
happened to the place where is it and i
said here and it's here
and that was it so it ran for a short
time then i got in trouble because
mccarthy days came along and i have as
you gather a big mouth
so i would talk at rallies anti-jim crow
anti-poll tax
pro
price control rent control and i signed
all these petitions and one day they
come from new york and they say
gee you are a valuable property
i like that phrase you know you and you
can go to new york and post one of those
shows which of course would be like
falling off a log
and i say but they're in trouble though
because you signed all these petitions
yes don't you know tommy and i started
those things and that's when i get smart
too smart and i say well suppose
communists come out against cancer must
we come out automatically come out for
cancer
and people laugh when i tell them that
this guy said that's not very funny
and finally they said you know why did
you say you were duped
you were fool
i said but i wasn't i and to this day
people say stud you were heroic they
don't know what they're talking about i
was scared
you know
crapless i was scared but uh
my ego was at stake
my vanity was at stake i mean i'm dumb
i'm not stopping so so it's really my
vanity
that did it and i lost the job and was
out for a while and i got onto the
station as a result and then one day i
had you jackson she i used to play my
handy jackson records i was the white
disc jockey man you always said i
acquainted white america whether it was
not
somewhat true and so she says
i must be the host of her program on cbs
radio
and she insisted one day a guy comes in
from new york and he says you got to
sign this it's a loyalty oath i said i
don't sign those things and we had you
passed by is that what i think it is
baby she'd say she knew about me in my
big mouth she said you should've been a
preacher because you got such a big
mouth anyway so she says to him listen
if you fire studs because you won't sign
that tell mr big to find another mahalia
jackson you know what happened he
disappeared he vanished the show went on
the morals say no nobody said no back in
those days
she didn't how old are you
i'm 88 when i was born the year the
titanic sank that so may 16th i'll be
88.
titanic went down i came up but then
a jimmy carter said who said life was
fair you know so
that's it and so
so he got the story of my life and you
were 45 when this book came out giants
of jazz oh that was early uh 1957.
however yeah about that
that's right that's written for
see that's not part of a series of oral
histories i've written ten years before
it's for young people
thomas y crowe uh from king oliver to
john coltrane
and you know written for young people
owner vicious
but jazz and so belly holidays and the
duke of course
then
10 years then 1965 or so i got that
phone call from andre schifrin and
that's something else
let me
go back though to the jazz book and then
we'll talk about some of the people who
you met along the way but you say that
um
jazz is the music of multitudes so few
famous so many nameless
for more than 70 years these musicians
have been playing and singing jazz
millions have been hearing it it could
have only happened here in the u.s
well it is that music of munchie jazz
remember you saw this probably as a
series of ken burns
which is i think a good series has many
flaws and of course video missions but
it's a good series you know jazz's
origins of course are african-american
african as well as white input as well
marvelous white jazz artists but
basically it was an expression it was
it's connected with
spirituals with work songs
with all sorts of code songs slavery
days on so a new form came in it was
improvisation
using whatever means you can
whether you're enslaved or free in name
jazz
blues is an aspect of jazz and i love
blues i love mahalia i love big bill
brunsi the greatest of all country blue
singers little known
people speak of muddy waters now they
were disciples of big bill
and the blues is what you can describe
blue blues is all the things i wanted to
be whatever i got around to being you
know woke up this morning blues was
around my bed ate my breakfast bruises
in my bread blue is the feeling
blue is a landlord knocking at the gate
blues is a woman on a poor man's mind
these are all definitions
ten years later division street america
came out in 1967.
that was the big one and that was andre
schifrin is responsible my publisher the
only one i've had he was a random house
then and then they were bought by a
billionaire who thought books should be
like detergents or deodorants you sell
and he was forced out in his new press
he called me one day and said he read
some of my interviews he's you know what
it was during the time of the
civil rights movement
anti-war movement time of the
cybernetics revolution
how about you doing a book about a
village he published a book about a
chinese village heated
by jan mirdel report
what happened to the small chinese
village because of the revolution
to the small village woman unbound her
feet etc how about you tackling an
american village chicago jurgen i said
you out of your mind
but he was right so we did division in
america they got some sort of
acclaim from readers and critics and
then one then he said how book about the
depression the young people are nothing
about the great american depression so i
did that book and so
that's how it began
our guest is studs terkel he'll be
joining us for the next two hours and 20
minutes our phone lines are open at
202-737-0001 if you live in the eastern
or central time zones and for those of
you in the mountain and pacific time
zones the number two zero two seven
three seven zero zero zero two
you talked about this book hard times
and in the book
you write about an invisible scar during
the depression
what are you talking about the invisible
scars the phrase
man what's her name again wrote the book
invisible scar is depression survivors
having certain quirks like gathering
things i turn out lights wherever i go
counter i don't know tell you what i
always turn out lights so there's a
group i was interviewing there the
animals they called the british like the
beatles
eric burden was there and he he's a
college kid but they speak street talk
as the kids did and college kids did
during the 60s
and they got the lights on we're going
downstairs to eat i interview them and
they got the lights going they got the
tv set going so i'm turning out the
lights what are you doing for cameron
hilton
you can buy a bottle for jazza gabor or
something well i'm of a different
generation
some people i know gather things
uh invisible scar a waitress i know says
she can't stand sardines because in the
orphan home which is a poor kid in the
depression that squash sardines all the
time so
so these are quirks but mostly it's the
insecurity but the big scar is one of
keeping quiet
of not telling their kids what it was
like the only time kids are told you
never had it so good instead of saying
what was it like the humiliation of
wanting to work and not finding a job to
be on relief which is the equivalent of
welfare today you see so you were a
teenager during the great depression yes
i was well it did the
1929 the crash officially began in 29 or
there was an agricultural depression
before that but in that october day 1929
bang
and i was well i would i was
1929 i was 17 years old yeah and and
this i might as well get a look in here
before we hear uh questions
uh we worship the free market it's our
new religion right and we say too much
big government as molly ivins would put
it too much big gun it was big
government that saved the hides the
bottoms of the daddies and granddaddies
those most condemned today
because i was talking to a guy i was
like alan greenspan of his day he was a
senior partner at goldman sachs advisor
to truman and to kennedy and i said what
happened he's i don't know what happened
that you don't know no guys jumped out
of windows ticket tape going on all
night and then we waited for some kind
of an announcement nice announcement
from home from god announcement came
from the new deal
the alphabet agent to save them
so we see we forgot all that and i the
purpose of all these books is to recall
history from the bottom up because we're
suffering i think my national
alzheimer's disease there's no memory of
yesterday
let alone what happened 50 years ago
it applies to world war ii as well it
applies to everything right and so in a
sense that's my ray's own debt for doing
this stuff
what kind of a name is turkle where does
it come from well trickle my parents
came way back 1903 a big migration
eastern europe polish russian border
taylor she was a seamstress
and it became a 1903
new york then i was born 1912 we moved
to chicago father was ill and when the
rooming house and then the hotel
and both those played
tremendous roles there was some
conversation in getting ready for this
interview with circle where the
conversation before this interview would
studs turkey wear his
checkered shirt his red socks red socks
only two other guys wear red socks
gareth and keeler
my friend whom i like very much garrison
keeler and the other is van johnson the
movie actress i said well what a
quinella
we three as far as i know where red sox
why
oh i like
i don't it's the color of life
but some some used to say color of your
politics studs
but no it's the i like red garibaldi had
red shirts and so that's basically why i
like it you know i once saw a guy with a
checked shirt he looked good his name
was wright morris a wonderful
writer photographer from nebraska i
support that guy looks good forgetting
that he's a handsome guy to begin with
and so that's how i got to wear it
checking shirts before we get our first
call let me ask you about uh your
picture in the cover of uh this book
again by tony parker two things first of
all the cigar
and rubber bands which are in your i
don't know i haven't got one here now
it's a fetish or something my wife my
wife she used to say
uh that's a fetish
i don't like rubber bands uh the the
cigar i do still smoke but privately i'm
aware of
the malorous effects of it so in so i
get a room and it says smoking you know
and i do it privately puff away and i
have two martinis a day
two cigars a day i tell you 88 what
difference does it make you know
huntington new york for studs turkle
you're on book tv go ahead please
go ahead caller hello
oh thank you very much i'm uh i feel so
privileged to be able to talk to you mr
uh terkel
um
my question is
the news media today
your view of it and
how much news it's really delivering to
the american people and how
how much
is it being
filtered how is the news being filtered
how much were you raising a key question
of course
think of that now who are the pundits
who are they who declared they are our
our mentors you know we start thinking
of
being filtered fewer and few we know
that fewer and fewer powers control more
and more thing and more of us feel more
and more helpless we know nbc is owned
by general electric right uh
westinghouse owns cbs
uh disney owns abc
murdock owns god knows what fox and
whatever so can you imagine of the
anchor people who are all good men by
the way
the scandal involving general electric
and tom brokas i want to tell you about
general electric of what happened
and the scandal how they've taken off on
the american public he'd be out in this
augusta gal for tomorrow see so you see
so
there has to be some kind of open more
openness i believe in i have a
suggestion something called soapbox
everybody
a blue ribbon committee of intellectuals
and people of thought not just
intellectuals others
to to give everyone a shot at it
at at
the prime time something called soapbox
no matter how goofy the idea is
but voices to be heard that are not
heard
and we have the same routine again let's
not talk about the last election which
we know as a farce we know that w.c
fields wrote it
it made it right out of burlesque you
know
think about it
five political hacks think about it now
in judicial robes good judges elected
our chieftain
and the other votes weren't counted
that's wc fields see i i experience
epiphany now and then this is now it's
not paul on the road to damascus this is
coming to the question i was not i got
struck by no blazing light but when
during the hearings on cnn we heard
a voice and that was justice o'connor
one of the five saying oh my goodness
when she said oh my goodness i was
transported back 70 years ago in the
burlesque house in chicago starring
garter theater now blessed houses have
five chief people the first banana he's
the top comic the second banana his
stooge the straight man at the foil the
talking lady would come to her in a
moment and the others the roused about
comical fills in and they they put on
trials comic trials and burlesque robes
they say here you hear me well i watched
that that saturday
the first banana was scalia the second
banana was clarence thomas
in minstrel blackface
the third was the straight man randquist
the talking lady in burlesque is the
girl of the chorus the one they choose
one who can spell cat and she takes part
in all the sketches the sketch always
involved a girl in bed with a guy now
her husband husband comes in with a gun
where is he where is he and she's
against the wall saying oh my goodness
that was her line and as soon as justin
kind of said that i was transported back
the fifth was
kennedy who was the fifth guy in
burlesque baggy pants putty nose
trousers so it's comic it was a
burlesque show
because of burlesque and the overall
producer is wc fields
we have a new chieftain
so that's by way of answering this
question
does the news cover this no it doesn't
uh we accept it as a matter of course
we're serious about it yes we're serious
instead of challenging something
happened to what madison and
tom payne were all about
if you can't get through on our phone
lines you can email us at booktv
cspan.org and we'll incorporate your
email questions over the course of the
next
two plus hours los angeles for studs
turkle go ahead please first of all let
me say good morning and thank you for
the opportunity this is the first time
i've ever called in on book tv
uh and a hearty hello to mr stutz turco
um i would like to uh commend him for
the book that he's written i'm not a
particular a jazz fan
but it is historical and the book that
he's written with regards to
familiarizing young people with what
it's about how it came about and
the people that uh really
promoted it it was a part of their lives
uh but i would like for him if you would
mr turkle if you would just elaborate
just a little bit on mahalia jackson
i tell you it's so many people
coming up now that don't know about her
if you could just elaborate
personally with regards to the great
mahalia jackson oh thank you very much
one of my favorite subjects one of my
closest friends
while she was alive mahalia jackson died
on mozart's birthday i was doing my
radio program i was going to relax it
was an eclectic program everything and i
was doing tribute to mozart that
birthday when someone
in the studio who knew i had to hang on
as a guest many times
she hands me the ticker tape man you
died this morning
and started some top emotes up here i
ran into behavior by accident i'm in a
book store in a music shop rather i'm
hearing a record it's called apollo as a
label 78 rpm to go move on up a little
higher song written for her by thomas a
dorsey professor dorsey is the great
writer of gospel music and
he wrote precious lord take my hand
which is dr king's favorite song and of
course mahalia was his favorite singer
so i hear that record in a record shop
and i dropped the record
like i never heard a voice like that so
i go to see her at the greater salem
baptist church where she was we became
close friends and so i played her record
again all the songs of hers and then
through the years mahelio said that i
was the white disc jockey who acquainted
white america with it well it would have
happened anyway i'm sure that but it
played a role because i played
continuously so me had you had a way
of singing
she called it demonstrating by the way
the word demonstration is interesting
that is
she she was very funny she did a take
off on singers who had their hands
folded like that and eyes closed she
would move
and move into the congregation as you
know the shaking of the hands and so
that's called demonstrating moving in
when she thinks that climbing jacob's
ladder or josh with the battle of
jericho or some of the gospel music of
professor dorsey and you know in the
upper rooms and
so
behavior was
just great her voice just soared
you know mary anna's not a certain kind
of voice my hair you had another kind of
voice but behind you i always used to
say man you was a young one she worked
in new orleans when she
lived it swept other people's kitchens
and worked she listened to bessie smith
the blue singers records
and i always said if bessie smith sang
spirituals she'd sounded like mahalia
jackson if he had you sang blues but she
never did she'd sound like bessie smith
and so in a way there was that
similarity but she was special i'm glad
you asked that question when did your
radio program end
well marie i
quit about three years ago because i
wanted to work on some more books
and i i would play repeats a lot and i
couldn't just do radio program every day
because i used to read the books
completely authors like being on my
program because it's all marked and
hieroglyphics and everything i had some
three four in the morning reads and i
couldn't
do it anymore because i had these books
in mind and so it worked out well now
and with the historical society
an email from alan harris-stein who says
in 1997 president clinton honored you as
america's oral historian and you were at
the white house what does it mean to be
the most visible oral historian in
america and how did your career in radio
train you for that i don't know what it
means you mean
i have no idea
i i was called i said yeah that's an
honor and i was there with
him and his wife hillary clinton
and it was a pleasant pleasant
experience oral historian by the way
uh
i'm not sure i'm a historian historian
gary wills is a preeminent historian
he's a scholar worried many things but
i'm i call myself a gorilla journalist
that is i know my terrain that knew my
terrain as the colonial soldiers did
against the british redcoats over that
matter the vietnamese soldiers did
against us we were the red coats there
they knew that terrain
and so i said no my terrain the first
book was chicago
you know
division street america which is a
metaphor i meant division street the
country divided but it's about chicago
profits and gains during the past half
century and so i'm a guerrilla
journalist rather than a but i'm called
an oral historian so i let it pass at
that
nashville tennessee you're next for
studs turkle good afternoon steve thank
you so much for bringing on a gentleman
that i absolutely adore i love you studs
turkle
i have two points that i'd like to make
this morning and i i'd like you to
reiterate on those
this week on broadcast news we heard
that ricketts
is coming back to america that young
children are experiencing rickets can
you imagine that we haven't had rickets
since the great depression and yet here
we are in this great wealth
having children come up with lack of
nutrients
second point i'd like to make is this mr
turkle
in the campaign of 2000
george w
campaigned around this country
uh with the thought that social security
was a private function that it was not
part of our great government
in protecting our elderly citizens this
is a man who has a trust fund
for his pension a man with millions
being given to him by the government and
yet he thinks social security is a
private
system
well of course you realize both your
questions are connected
the rickets and the attack on social
security are connected ricketts that
little kids would get during the great
depression or in poverty-stricken
countries coming back not surprised are
we see whenever something happens and we
say too much big government i say big
government you know molly ivan is so
brilliant she's taken off on texas talk
but big government and i just
watch your pocket watch your wallet you
know and social security
is what makes older people those who
have modest income or less income a
little a little place in the sun a
little security some sort you know that
came about it wasn't the new deal itself
it was the crazies at that time my wife
was a young social worker at the time
when she first came across the phrase
social security it was a guy
uh who's something of a nut it seems who
crashed a gathering of big shots
who didn't know what was happening the
depression hit and he somehow he leaped
high
on the banister onto a chandelier and he
swung back and forth hollering we need
social security for the old they
arrested and put them on a psychiatric
care but that's the first time it made
the headline
front page in her mind you see and of
course
for bush to say it's private
privatization when i hear that word
i just hold on to my wallet whatever i
have privatization means the government
please don't roll privatizing every
privatization what we have in the 20s
nobody see investing in stock is now and
then comes the crash and something's
going to happen i don't know what it
won't happen the same way and they were
saved by regulation government
having a benign role i don't mean just
swelling the pentagon's pocket with
something goofy like the
star wars thing that was conceived by
ronnie you know the star wars he sold us
on it francis fitzgerald has a book on
that subject way out there in the blue
it's it's it's he saw a bullet stopping
a bullet and such a movie sort of and we
bought it in the name of security it
doesn't work billions go for that
but when it comes to health education
and welfare
of course you try to privatize that
which means which leads to rickets of
course
many ailments of course it will both
connected we live in a strange chaotic
moment when
tom paine wrote common sense it's not
just
freedom free to vote freedom
citizenry
thoughtful citizenry the key was
thoughtful thinking citizenry they're
trying to lobotomize us you see that's
what's happening
so your question questions are really
one question
philadelphia you're next oh please mr
turkle it's a it's an honor to speak
with you i want to congratulate you on
your righteous work and also on your
longevity uh i was wondering if you were
in chicago in december of 1967 and
remember uh the incident surrounding the
murder of fred hampton by the chicago
police and also if you could talk about
your experience of the black panthers
over your journalistic career
one 1968 convention you meant i guess
yeah oh no when fred hampton was killed
by the chicago police in december 67
prior to the chicago convention oh is
that you mean the murder of fred hampton
yes sir well fred hampton was a very
black panthers had to sort of check out
history but black panthers had breakfast
for kids and fred hampton was a
non-violent guy
and he was just he was shot and ed han
ryan was the
attorney general in
charge of the group the cops went in and
just shot him as simple as that
and was horrendous of course that caused
the furor and later on hannah was beaten
for office
but that was
all the all these were precursors you
might say to what happened in 68
and 68 convention of course was pretty
wild
and that's so funny
i remember
seated there at the conrad hilton hotel
which is across the street
balboa and michigan
and across the street is where the tear
gas was in fact the tear gas permeated
the whole area the journalists were all
inside this haymarket bar interesting
name hay market after haymarket affair
and we couldn't get out because the m8rd
says you can't get out it's too
gas
and it brought back a memory to me that
same corner 33 years before 1935 there
was a demonstration because the street
was named balboa that day
see balboa
was the minister of aviation in the
mussolini
and
there was a flotilla of planes a flight
from rome to chicago and he was being
honored the street was named after him
balboa was also the head of the
expedition that dropped the first bombs
ever on civilians before the spanish
civil war on ethiopia
dropped the bombs and so there was a
protest there i was a bystander at the
time i just had acquaintances who were
protesting i thought that same corner
and no one questioned the name balboa
you know it's chicago streets named
schubert and early liberal germans came
to chicago part of its early culture was
liberal german
and john peter altkill was a great
governor who came from germany and he's
the great governor who pardoned
of the haymarket uh survivors that was a
famous case in 1886.
they were german analysts campaigning
for the eight hour day
someone threw a bomb no one knows who to
stay and so the speakers that went out
there three were hanged four were hanged
and the three were hanged
and four were
he pardoned the four ruined his career
but
his ethics meant more so all that comes
to mind you don't mind if i ramble a bit
because it's all related everything's
everything this book race how blacks and
whites think and feel about the american
obsession this is the paperback edition
and early in the book you write that
since the election of ronald reagan in
1980
the hostility towards civil rights
legislation was interpreted as something
of a friendly wink toward those whose
language may be more gamey than civil
what do you mean by that well you see
the whole idea
what is affirmative action really you
think about it i used a phrase called
affirmative civility
she's nothing more than affirmative
civility
recognizing the presence or the rights
of another person like as you can gather
i talk a lot i also talk to myself when
i walk down the street and i find the
audience very appreciative
and so i'm talking to myself and i see a
woman passing by a middle-aged black
woman toting two heavy bags
that she's worked in someone's kitchen
and
she's has enough frown but she's tired
and she hears me say i said it matters
how's it going she is my voice
how's it going you know what she says
her voice breaks them she says fine and
you and you how are you so three kids
are going by three young teenage black
kids it's got they got that walk you
know they're walking by
jelly roll morton you say doing the iggy
a certain kind of walk they had how does
that go yeah well just that so i'm
walking by this elderly old white guys
walking by three the kid in the center
you know it deleted him so and they hear
me say they're going along and letting
them say i said how's it going
it's fine and you
and you
so what have i done a fro i take
the affirmative civility
affirmative action is we recognize
people who have not been recognized and
the rights to a job have not been
written and so basically affirmative
civility means we teach our kids to
behave civilly don't we and yet they
were opposed to affirmative action
hypocrites building without even
realizing it you know and teaching your
kids something else
you can say you can you can teach it to
talk in french
the kid can say a mercy and can still be
a barbaric kid
you see so
what is
civil
civil is the recognizing another person
when james baldwin wrote nobody knows my
name
but i know your name well of course we
know for a long time blacks were
invisible ralph ellison's novel was
called the invisible man or now visible
but visible six o'clock news all the
time some crime young and young black is
there no other black life no other
african-american life you see so
basically that's what i meant by that
what's your party affiliation what's
right party affiliation democrat i'm
independent like i came out for ralph
nader but towards the end i said we got
to go from score
whether we like it or not because the
other thing would be disastrous of
course
uh but i'm independent uh i think we
need a new force i think by the way i
have a suggestion for president i i'm
gonna try a brush for just an idea let's
try this out for size i have an idea who
could be our next president the best
president we've had since franklin d
roosevelt he's known his name is known
to millions of americans his voice is
known to millions of americans he has
never held political office but he's
been involved in politics now who am i
thinking of
oh i'll drop you another hint he was
press agent press secretary for lbj
we'll stop you there we'll see if a
caller or two can figure out who it is
fresno california
i'm talking about he has documentaries
integrity
is the words we love to use integrity
intelligence which we haven't used and
compassion whom i think enough i'm sure
they guessed it let's see fresno
california any clue
i would stab at bill moyers you got it
your stab is right on the button now
what about you we don't think in those
terms at all do we we think gore
automatically or get part or or cheney
or
w god help us but think about better
myers
he's had it
think about it now
the three words we love to use integrity
compassion
and then but in the key word here is
intelligence
but of course
so how does that sound to the great
money i'm trying to start a brush fire
now
to make his name known
as a possible my presidential candidate
and see how that goes fresno what do you
think
well i have to read a little bit in
depth about uh mr moyer's
programs that he would embark on and but
i'm fascinated
by studs
thoughts of
mr moyers as a candidate for president
it's indeed an honor
and a joy to talk to him because
my call is a little unique originally my
father a shoe buyer for a major chicago
department store chain
and a 1928 graduate of the university of
chicago and had a graduate degree in
1930
he was thought to be
a an interview in working in your book
studs who is that
well his name was archie wirth
and instead he declined he was quite
modest so my mother ruth worth
who's still living at evanston in about
four weeks from being 91 years old
and is not
with all her faculties unfortunately and
i live in fresno california so my mother
was included in the book
and uh that book has been part of my
adult life i'll be darned ever since and
then there's one other antidote with
your commentary and observations about
1968
i was a young stockbroker in the board
of trade building
we played in a softball league amongst
all the other brokerage firms
we were in grant park the afternoon of
the riots playing in a league game a
softball league game and someone noticed
near the end of our game about the last
inning
hordes of people coming over the
embankments that come down into the ball
fields and it seemed like just you know
just an enormous amount of people and
they were carrying baseball bats and
they seemed unruly and it wasn't
obviously was something we had never
seen before so we walked up the backside
of grant park and by the time we got
across michigan avenue to just south of
the hilton we started walking towards
the hotel we saw broken windows we
retraced our steps and went along
some of the back streets before we could
get back to uh the board of trade
offices but that was a
memorable day a frightful day
and certainly an experience that also
has not left my memory but but your
writings and your commentary and when i
was younger on fm radio and
have been part of a
scenario of growing up and then being
incorporated in my adult life via my
parents
and then your comments this morning
about 1968
it's just a
unique opportunity to enjoy to
visit a few moments with you and i'm
glad i was able to get bill moyers thank
you
now one more thing thank you very much i
like that idea by the way when people
call and someone would say to me after
reading working let's say and he says
i'll never again talk to a waitress the
way i did because there's a waitress in
it and she cleans your work see i like
that or i'll never again think about an
interstate truck driver as the menace
because this industry tells what his
life is like i like that but back on the
moyer's theme again the republican party
did it you know in 1940 they nominated
an unknown lawyer from indiana named
wendell wilkie and he ran against the
unbeatable fdr third term in 1940 but he
made a very respectable more than that
when the wilkie turned out to be a
remarkable man very enlightened even
more enlightened than fdr in some
respects so you see
moyers
on the on on the other hand is known to
millions so there's been a precedent for
this is what i'm saying
last september chicago tribune
interviewed you about the 2000 campaign
and you said quote
if it turns out that i'm dead wrong and
w referring to george w bush heaven
forbid is our president i shall run for
the hills the chariots of fire in hot
pursuit did you well i i'm still not
running for the hills i should run for
the hills but the fact is
i know that
that ralph nader is blamed because the
florida thing i think he should have
withdrawn i think he should have
withdrawn before the florida campaign
but i'm not sorry he ran because he
raised issues that neither raised that's
about where things were hearing about
corporate power and what it's doing and
so in that sense uh many millions by the
way voted who would not have voted we
forget about that word not for nader but
however he should have withdrawn of
course well i should be running for the
hills i suppose but i've got too big a
mouth
still around talking
why has this book working received so
much attention
because working
you know freud wrote a book called
civilization and discontents and the two
prime impulses of man are leaving an
arabic love and work love meaning sex
a lot of books about sex more than we
need really but very few books written
about our daily lives our daily work
lives and for the first time
i gathered
it's been there many now
what's it like see i opened up almost
biblically with three
occupations that scriptural the
carpenter and of course jesus the
carpenter the mason tower
and the farmer and that begins with
a laborer a steel laborer who reads now
and then and he you read yes i read
what's the traces but i i'll never be
remembered for what i do so now and then
he bang out a ingot of steel just to put
a dent in it's my dent he someday i'd
like to see a building
a skyscraper with a name it has the name
of the architect at the bottom i don't
see a strip of metal from the top story
at the bottom with the name of every
person involved with that skyscraper so
iron work i could point to that one and
say i put that piece of iron in that
50th floor or the glazer i put that
window in or the scrub woman as i clean
those offices elevators i operate the
elevator a person must have something to
point to
and so in a sense
that book
dealt with the theme of daily work work
telephone operator everything and a
gravedigger
gravedigger housewife you write about
elmer ruiz not anybody can be a
gravedigger you can dig a hole any way
they come
a gravedigger you must have must make a
neat job i had a fellow once he wanted
to see a grave he was a fellow that did
sewers he was impressed when he had seen
me dig in this grave
how'd you find him yeah i was even he
was proud of his work
even digging a grave you see
yet the same time he was human sometimes
i wear i wear dark glasses even though
he doesn't know the person when a child
lies something
and i wear dark glasses so as to not
show my tears
so he's still human at the same time
proud of his craft too
harrisburg pennsylvania you're next yes
hello i'm coming to harrisburg oh great
yeah sometimes the legislature
to talk about the good war well we'll
talk about good war in a moment about
the war and the depression
anyway i'd like to ask if you have any
experience or could talk about nelson
algren
i believe he's the most underrated
writer we have
you're talking my language nelson aldrin
was a friend of mine maybe listeners
that don't know nelson is he was the
lyrical he won the first
national book award for the man with the
golden arm he's known for that
which he thought was a terrible movie
but nelson aldrin is sort of bard of
chicago wrote a little book called
chicago city on the make and it's just a
love-hate
story you can't love a city you can just
to love it's boulevard love its alleys
as well so he wrote of chicago and of
the world behind those billboards not
simply the drive from
along
the lakeshore drive and the beautiful
lake we have which is true
but west of it and so he was the bard of
chicago but he did right even though he
wrote tough novels and short stories he
was a literary he was lyrical he was
poetic in the writing of it
i'm glad you brought up his name nelson
aldrin do you have a favorite place in
chicago what's that a favorite place
well we did have a place the watering
hole for writers and general journalists
nad guys core ricardo's
rick ricardo
like rick's in casablanca
rick ricardo was a guy who
elegant guy sort of a don giovanni
figure he escaped mussolini and during
the depression he had the place in art
he was an artist of sorts but he'd have
he'd carry him on the tab he'd never
collect open harness and then he opened
the place big during the beginning of
world war ii
and uh it was a it's no longer there now
it's a in place for generation x so
lost where those those landmarks are
gone
if you've just joined us our
conversation with studs turkle here on
book tv part of our in-depth series our
email and phone lines are open if you
want to
fax in or phone in or email your
question one from
uh alan stein who said how did the
blacklist affect your life
well in a strange way it helped
i don't mean to suggest being
blacklisted it's a career move i'm not
trying to it happened my life was
accidentally uh if it were not for the
blacklist i would
i was i was courted
when stud's place was hot nearly shown
garaway at large and mike wallace went
to new york he was chicago announced i
went to new york at the time and i was
courted by new york hotshots to go there
i probably would not have gone i would
have stayed in school but would probably
would have hosted this show
and made some prob
good dough but i would have died in the
meantime with some kind of restaurant my
wife said
my wife who
who died uh
a couple of decembers ago
is quite remarkable anyway uh she said
you'd have been fired anyway studs you
and your big mouth you know you'd have
said something so chance i'd been fired
anyway
but because i was blacklisted
i was home and i do a lecture now and
then on jazz and folk music for women's
clubs and they were pursued by a
legionnaire in town whose life was
uh i was his pigeon but to get after
people he thought were
we he called the legionnaires
called subversive
and so he followed them around but none
of them gave into him i will say that
they were a little scared and so and
then i heard this radio station wfmt
uh this station is now the finest fine
arts station in the world we won all
sorts of awards and that was the 1952
and i said i'd like to work for you guys
because i heard them play a record a
woody guthrie dust bowl record no
station played except me when i was a
disc jockey boy so they said we'd love
to have you they knew me but we're broke
as i am too so we started even that was
there 45 years so in a sense the
blacklist
i wouldn't have written these books for
it not for the i'm not suggesting people
go on the blacklist you know
anyway
let me go back and just spend a moment
to talk about your wife she was born in
northern wisconsin and in the book by
tony parker she tells a story
about her mom she was one of six
children
she was ill
and she basically her mother made
an agreement with god what was that all
about well that was if if uh
if she recovered my wife was the flu
epidemic was going on then you know the
great flu epidemic that killed millions
you know how old was she at the time
how old was she she had the same age no
but when she was ill
average six or seven i guess
and if she recovered she'll two more
kids and she did
but
how can i describe her we're married 60
years social worker and she was well
people say
gary wills when he first met her said
she said oh she's like a girl so she she
was 86 but
she's i still feel like a girl jerry
will said remember when she'd greet him
oh it's years after the vietnam war we
were arrested together in washington and
my neighbor across the street saw her
picking weeds out of our lawn
and she saw someone
a girl
with a flower in her hair and jeans
a girl slimming girl looked up
and it was ida see
and gwendolyn brooks the the poet
brendan brooks who died he said
about my wife she could dance on a
moonbeam so
you say she lived full life 87.
that doesn't mean anything
that doesn't mean as a phrase that myra
mcpherson used one of her books called
disenfranchised grief you're not
supposed to grieve you say
good life not supposed to since when you
see
and so well of course
i grieve
and the book is
in fact dedicated to her this one
forthcoming which is about everything i
hope will see
she died when what's that december
uh
1999
didn't make the didn't make the uh new
millennium
you have one son what's that you have
one son yeah and he's wonderful what's
his name my name is dan and he's
he's my um
gibraltar
denver you're next with studs turkle on
book tv
yes mr turkle you've had the pleasure of
watching the
the one of the greatest mayors of our
time mayor daley the the father and
you've also watched uh rudy giuliani how
would you compare the two
rudy giuliani and the current mayor
the former his father well i don't know
they're both different uh
i don't know new york as well as chicago
live boring i don't know uh both were
authoritarians of course
uh daley's power of course daily had
more power as a matter of fact young
mayor daddy probably more power the old
man without
without even asserting himself because
the opposition is so confused mixed up
now then there was some opposition
giuliani of course is self-righteous and
we know about his attempts to censor
things
that are you know should not be censored
and uh
there's some similarity in the
authoritarian aspects i think
but aside from that i'm
not too up on it but it would be
nasa city long island you're next go
ahead please
hello
hello i'm with you i'd like to say to mr
terkel to begin with that
i use his book
during the time when i place students on
jobs and set up training programs
and i think that the book is is very
well done and i was just wondering if
anyone has taken off on
some of the things that you uh
started uh when you wrote this book
oh yeah well you mean the book working
are you referring to working working yes
well yeah as a matter of fact the book
has just come out my pup put out by rick
ayers a-y-e-r-s
the use of working in a classroom that
very i forget the name of it but using
the book in the classroom just as you
did it's coming out now i think it's out
now in in paperback
new press the very thing oh it's been
there many variations on working a lot
of them
one
book called not working being idle i was
a book by sydney lewis who did the
transcribing for me i'll tell you about
that in a moment how i work people like
the uh and she's
written a book
that's not out about first
young people the first jobs they have
and so
there were a lot of variations on that
theme which i'm happy to see
out of all of the people who you have
met and interviewed over the years
does anyone stand out
that's like asking them to choose
some of several children's a favorite
child
there's no one that stands out the last
one i'm working on see right now the one
that stands out when i just finished
because it's the one
it's about death that is it but it's the
liveliest book i've ever written i call
it
will the circle be unbroken it's the old
hymn
doc watson sings johnny cash ap carter
with a circle being broken by and by
lord by and boy there's a better homo
waiting in the sky lord in the sky will
the circle be unbroken
and as legacy it continues so that's the
name of the book the subtitle is
reflections on death rebirth and uh
hunger for a faith there's that hunger
for a faith whether you're agnostic or
you know what an agnostic is i am an
agnostic is a cowardly atheist
he's a guy he wants to make sure
anyway so
hunger for a faith people who have a
faith
and people often say in the book you
find something interesting i'm not
religious but i'm spiritual they won't
have a faith but they won't be
associated with institution
and people who have a faith of that sort
are better off that doesn't find more
solace
than people who don't who say like
gertrude stein said of oakland there's
no there there nada you know and i i may
believe that but i respect the others
and they're in the book and suddenly i
realized that they're better off than
someone like me they say they're better
off because there's something
because when king lear carries cordelia
in his arms at the end
the one he really loves who loved him
the only one who did he's never never
never never never fight
well he see her or feel her breath again
and so
boy
so that book is about that but it's also
funny
and it's full of life
that's my favorite book at this moment
because i've just finished it you see
does death frighten you
no it doesn't now no no now it doesn't
flip i don't welcome it you know but i
intend to keep working
dying with my hand on the typewriter or
asleep perhaps but does it frighten me
i don't like the i mean i want to hang
around because i got another book after
this in mind you see
if you see that's the trouble with
technology that i'm condemning and
advances in science you're living longer
than
why would someone want to live i'm going
to be 88 right may 16th now why would
someone want to live to be 90. and burt
uh churchill refused to have said
everybody was 89
wants to live to be 90. so in a sense
yeah i want to see next year
see was happening curious my epitaph i
know curiosity did not kill this cat
that's it
back to the emails doug perry give my
school district and school board two or
three reasons why reading your oral
history hard times
will provide students with more learning
and enjoyment than reading two chapters
of on the great depression from any
history textbook
well that's what he said well i like
that now you want to comment on that
well he wants a couple of reasons on why
this should be part of the curriculum
why it should be part of the curriculum
the great depression what do we know
about the great depression ask any young
person they'll know something happened
they may get history books about world
war one veterans selling apples on
street corners they may get a word about
about uh
soup lines and then something happened
the war happened well the war did end
the depression that is new deal helped
tremendously it gave people jobs they
wouldn't have that private enterprise
the idea of the free market did not it's
not on its face the wall street journal
i done that wall street journal god help
me the the variety the trade paper when
the crash occurred had a headline wall
street lays an egg
i haven't got wall street telling us
what's going on again as though nothing
had happened what was it like
to be a boy or a girl
10 or 11 seeing his father her father
come home with a tool chest on her
shoulder come home 11 o'clock in the
morning and not work for the next 10
years what was it like
to be the mother what was it like to be
that family and not working or the
husband leaving out of despair and
desperation you connect that with
families today single then you see the
connection you see then you didn't use
phrases like the subculture or pathology
of etc we know it's racist connotation
most overwhelmingly will fight and
relief for today too most of white white
young
mothers single mothers but uh
what was the depression like from
to feed what it's like that's what is
needed to be in schools that's why i
think
that book
hard times is is essential yes i know
what's self-serving to say but i feel
it's true
should be in schools yeah
we are now in the second of our
three-hour conversation with studs
turkey our phone lines are open
202-737-0001 if you live in the eastern
or central time zones or
202-737-0002 if you live in the mountain
and pacific time zones how long does it
take for you to complete a book on
average well there's no rule there again
you see i work off and on when i was at
the radio station remember most this was
while i was still doing my radio shows i
would take time out
maybe two three months off and play
replay
tapes most requested
and so i wouldn't get on my bathrobe you
know like ballsack
and so
i would concentrate but off and on year
two years no no this came for some
reason this last book came quickly maybe
because i am at the historical society
and it came something seemed to fall
into place
we're going to take a call where you're
phoning from i'm calling from raleigh
north carolina go ahead please
uh my question
is actually not a question i want to
congratulate mr turkle uh because
as a former
citizen of the former soviet union i was
teaching american culture language and
history for many years
and way back in the 70s might be
fascinating from historical to find out
that i've been using a lot of his
writings along with phil bello norman
mailer
and
i feel like i'm honored uh tremendously
to be talking to the man who stood
behind all this enthusiasm you know i
was doing it at the risk
of being blacklisted which i was for so
many years
but uh the humanity the uh
the perspective that we are all
people living in
one world and basically uh are motivated
by pretty much the same things made him
a unique person i also use some of the
tapes that i obtained from american
armed forces radio and television
network and my students way back in the
70s were exposed to mr turtle's
brilliant writing thank you very much
well i'm very very moved thank you very
much for doing what you're doing
thank you chicago you're next with studs
turkey mr turkey i was ready to tell me
if you had your recent show on reading
world war ii letters
i saw something about it on tv but i
missed it if you've already had it how
did it go if you haven't had it are you
going to have another one well i didn't
i didn't miss that reading world war ii
what did you say letters letters oh well
i simply the station i was connected
with wfmt
is having a program of letters lots of
work of all wars no i have nothing i
simply did
the announcement uh they asked me if i
would announce it on television on the
public tv station but i have nothing to
do with it's doing i understand it's
going very well
uh scores of letters hundreds of letters
are coming in to the station wfmt
letters not simply world war ii small
wars so
that's about it
it'll be done during memorial day during
the memorial day weekend
you know your earpiece there's a little
oh yeah
this is my hearing aid i better explain
to the audience i'm the bionic man
sort of half bionic and these are
state-of-the-art so-called hearing aids
and i've got this hearing aid to hear
the voices
so
i'm
lumping
going around and about oh you do you
hear you hear a sound we're getting a
little feedback oh well his feedback now
i open it and of course i'll drop the
battery i'll put it right here remind me
to take it with me also you have a one
ear charlie you will get a call from
las vegas nevada with studs
uh yes good morning i'd like mr turkle's
opinion i know technology has helped him
a great deal but what does he think
about the telephone menus what does he
think that does to society and to uh to
the working force when you call some
place and you want an answer and you go
around and around and around talking to
a computer yeah my favorite question
in the old days you'd call up now i
don't mean to be a reactionary now
regressive well i am something of a lot
you know love was the farmer 18th
century
who offered the destruction of machines
but it wasn't that they wanted to learn
to use the machines that's putting them
out of work but you make a telling the
old days a human voice would answer i
says charlie there no what you tell them
stud's called sure
or if nobody's home when you try again
now you call
and a voice answers it's a machine right
and the voice answers this you one so
and so such and such push one push two
push three push
you get the six i forget who the hell it
was i caught it what i called about
and he and then it's and then you're
right you go nuts so i must tell you a
very quick story about
this age how we're becoming more and
more roboticized ourselves for years you
know we've talked about robots doing the
work of man that's true in doing working
i went to niles ohio i think it was just
outside youngstown when general motors
was putting out vega and it was a
disaster they weren't the ones to match
the foreign sports cars and this young
kid was head of the uaw there
points out to a unimate a unimate as a
robot at the end of the line that works
like a praying mantis back and forth
does the same work as people in the
machine
only doesn't take time out doesn't smoke
doesn't eat and doesn't organize
so we have robots imitating humans but
now humans are becoming roboticized now
atlanta airport some years ago
modern
you know
you leave the gate and you go into a
train trains quite to take you to the
concourse of your ultimate destination
you know you're on this train quiet as
soon as you come in
you hear a voice up above
you know it's a human voice but he's
speaking like a machine somebody says
concourse one you know that voice like a
robot
dallas lubbock fort worth you know
concourse ii springfield st louis that
voice just then it's about to take off
now the word is spoken a young couple
rush in and they push back the pneumatic
doors as you when you're on the elevator
you want to make and you push back but
without losing a beat that voice that's
because of late entry we're delayed 30
seconds everybody's looking at that
young couple maybe honeymooners looking
at them and those those two kids are at
the foot of calvary you know like that
and now i happen to have had a couple of
martinis
to steal myself for occasions of the
sword you know and so i do a takeoff i
do a take off on on
the train call like that remember i had
a couple of days i said george orwell
your timer's coming gone
well
you're laughing but uh nobody laughed
then they looked at me i suddenly
realized i'm with the couple with the
foot of calvary what's going on here no
human voice no nothing no humor or just
then i see a little baby about maybe a
six eight months old in the lap of the
mother and she's uh mexican or puerto
rico she's speaking spanish to her
friend and so i say to the baby you know
and i have my
cut my hand like this because my breath
is 100 proof and so i say to the baby
sir or madam what is your opinion of the
human species
and so what a baby do in a season known
a baby starts giggling i said thank god
a human voice so there's hope so in a
sense back to your question i know how
you feel
i go crazy
and finally i don't even i don't even
know to who and with my hearing aid on
top of everything
i'm i'm i'm talking to machines and i
think our own language is becoming that
way we find us among young people i have
a teacher friend who says he sees the
kids talking disjointedly in a way so
maybe we are imitating the robot right
the other way around
new york city you're next oh hi uh
speaking about talking about robots
there was a common list from your
city mike rocco
he seemed to speak for the common person
and
i believe he wrote an introduction to
one of his books and
if you can give me any comments about
that i'll hang up and listen and thank
you for being here today sure well mike
ryko was a friend of mine he was the was
he known to many
viewers mike of course was the columnist
there was no one quite like him he could
make you laugh cry he would do anecdotes
slat scrub nick very funny furious angry
at injustice in fact the one i wrote the
introduction for was the last one one
more time a new one had just come out
for the love of mike it's just coming
out
and uh it's new columns of mike so
reading him see that see mike was also
possessed by a demon although he
couldn't do this there was something in
him how could he do this thing every day
five days a week and for a long time
three days a week each one topping the
other so there was sort of a devil in
them
that
led to it i think let me ask you about
this book chicago when did it come out
well that book chicago is
my i said sort of
my my history of chicago i've got the
year it came out but it's nowhere nearly
as good as nelson organizing nelson
organs book chicago city on the make is
about the same size as that but there's
no comparison a nelson's is a far far
superior book
san diego you're next
well good morning thank you so much book
tv for bringing this treasure of two
american centuries to us this morning
uh thank you thank you said circle for
being you i have a book question for you
i happen to index books and i want to
know if you have any advice
for those of us who index books
for those of us i didn't get the last
one who indexed books
caller how long have you been doing that
you still with us she must have hung up
no i i didn't i didn't get she wanted
advice for anyone who indexes books
advice to do what i didn't get that i'm
sorry san diego are you still with us
hello
we lost i'm sorry i apologize i didn't
get it you've written 13 books what kind
of books you have written 13 books 13
books oh yeah i see well yeah about that
i didn't count must be about 30 with the
jazz book i guess about 13.
yeah and do you index the books that
you're learning
no
no he's i've got the tapes
transcribed oh by the way you know might
be good how
how i do it
the process
what is this i talk to people
and it's on a tape recorder
and then i give it to someone to
transcribe but i say don't miss a word
do it exactly don't even there's a
silence if there's a laugh keep that
laugh in very often you will find an
african-american would laugh and recount
a certain moment of humiliation
like my friend big bill brunsi the blue
singer was also artisan you know many
uh children of slaves and slaves were
artisans they could do carpenters could
do everything big bill was teaching a
young white kid how to be a welder and
as i taught the kid they fired me and he
laughed see now why do you laugh at a
moment of humiliation there's a blues
lyric laughing to keep from crying
today you might say laughing to keep
from raging and that's this big ben so
the laugh or whatever it is so i want
all that in that recreates for me the
the time i was interviewing that person
and then
i'm like a gold prospector that's the
analogy in 1849 gold was discovered in
california and here come all the covered
wagons in the conestoga wagons to
california pike speaker buster song
darning clementine 49ers
they heard there's a place there i heard
of a certain person
that's gold
now the gold prospector starts digging
and digging and digging i start having
the conversation with the person
and out of the gold prospectors digging
is all this ore a ton of ore an outcome
30 pages single space of transcription
well that can't be booked then you got
now the gold prospector starts filtering
sifting he's got a handful of gold dust
in his hand so i start editing and this
is a key moment the words that don't
change it's the words of the people but
how can i do it and still maintain its
truth you will have so here how can i
get these eight pages these ten pages
instead of the thirty
and and that's my hand full of gold dust
but that's still not a gold watch is it
it's still not a necklace or a ring how
you got a book so you connect that with
others back and forth and out of it
comes a book and that's the terrible
moment when you have to eliminate some
people who are just as good people in
the book then i become a director of a
play the two good actors
both are equally good i have to choose
the one who's best for the balance of
the cast
and so in this book i offer my apologies
to those whom i've interviewed who gave
me the precious time or not in the book
i include their names among my scouts so
people won't know they were rejected in
the book include their names and
acknowledgements so it's like i'm gold
prospector so now it's many steps are
involved
the key moment is the editing
oh how does it begin
i don't always start the same way
because no interview starts the same way
anyway about the depression well why
don't you like uh smash that why do you
like sardines it might be what's your
first memory of the depression i want
you for there's no rule about it so i
can alter things so long as i don't
alter that truth and let me go back to
the college point about indexing if one
goes to any library in the country where
would they find a studs turkle book
where in the library oh libraries i
don't they have different places
sociology history
non-fiction or what are they classified
to mean i don't know
history
where would you classify it
a whatnot you know what not as a what
not special furniture to use for
anything it's a what not so my book is a
what not it could be anywhere
history i suppose or sociology very
often history sociology too
there's no one rule oxnard california
you're next on book tv
yes thank you very much i have a
commentary uh i enjoy mr turkle's work
very much i am a librarian in california
and i've i'm familiar with several of
his works and i have them in the library
and of course when i was in college i i
read quite a bit of his material i just
have a general commentary or a question
really for mr turkle and that is
what do you think about librarians and
the work that they do
and uh just a general commentary on
librarianship i think librarians are
they heroes
i i could say heroes on heroines but
heroes is the word that's
all-encompassing of our society
librarians more teachers certain
teachers perhaps to are the key people
and the molding of young lives into
adult lives of some meaning not just
literacy of some meaning the librarian
very often and i imagine you in that
category
advise
young people
what to look at or read
librarians i think are among the most
underrated taken for granted heroes of
our society
let me go back to another one of your
books the great divide what's this about
well the great divide is about now too
it's called the subtitles second
thoughts on the american dream the book
before that was the american dream lost
and found lost and found as a takeoff on
amazing grace you know
amazing race how sweet they sound
that saved a wretch like me once was
lost but no one found the great divide
is not simply race it's everything the
divide between us
that in a sense
is represented by the last burlesque
at election too the great divide
certain kinds of people certainly why do
they what is best for our society for
all of us you see so the great divide is
with that difference
and i should ask our callers if there's
a particular book or a particular
individual uh that studs circle has
written about we hope you'll share that
with us as well as we get a call from
phillipsburg phillipsburg new jersey
with studs turkle go ahead please uh mr
turquoise it's an honor to speak to you
i'm an eighth grade english teacher and
as a follow-up to
teaching george orwell's animal farm
i like my eighth graders to do an oral
history of the cold war
you have any suggestions on how to
oh wow
that's an awfully good one that's a big
one or let's do the cold war
uh well i think there have been several
attempts at it but not an oral history
that would drop the offer that's a good
challenge i
can't tackle it
dude now i have another
thing in the fire i don't know if i can
but someone should do it absolutely i
think you start with anywhere start with
someone as close to john edgar hoover as
you could find that you can start with
an fbi guy if he'd be open up and talk
start with one of those guys there's no
rule
start with someone who had to fire a guy
or
a sight and a person himself or how a
person got to be
the the cold war
the very beginning well you have to
start also with natchez hitler style and
pact but before that what led to that
and what led to stalin for that matter
you have to go remember there was an
american expedition way way back to
knock off the revolution when it first
began in 1918 1917 wasn't there the red
cross worker what's his name wrote about
when wilson was president so you have to
go back way way back and
it's
it'd be a hell of a story
be a big one
the cold war
yes
oh before we close i have no idea how
much time we have we have time we have
an hour and a half oh good
to ask about the one interview
that
i most remember or we'll save that for
later okay that's what they call it the
audience will stay with us remind me of
that ohio
you're next with studs terkel good
afternoon mr circle i grew up listening
to your radio program i'm originally
from chicago in fact i grew up right by
division street in the humboldt park
here
uh and i carry some of those scars that
my parents suffered from the depression
because i still turn all the lights out
at home and i still make sure that i'm
pretty tight with a dollar although now
my we call people frugal
my comment is around humble park it was
rather a diversified neighborhood before
we had the term diversity in society
can you comment on the change in the
neighborhood there now and did the
melting pot in america ever exist
well you see neighborhoods are changing
right now as you know being reading
about the census the country will become
in time the white will be the minority
group with asiatic influx and the
hispanic particularly
and so humbled park became originally
way way back was jewish and polish now
it's hispanic primarily but now it's
being gentrified we have no
gentrification and what happens to the
people living there when the young
couples were a buck or two or the market
or they're gentrifying it what happened
to those people
one kid says i feel like i have a check
on a checkerboard we've been moved six
times you see and so
gentrification is the biggest change i
don't know where
those people go
i talked to a developer once i said what
what in the world where do the people go
he says he said he waved vaguely out
there
west out there so
changes are occurring well humble park
is now primarily hispanic but again
there's a fight against
this removal
how long was your program on
how long was the program daily on wfs it
was an hour show five days a week for 45
years
1952 to 1997.
when was it on the air what time of the
day at 10 o'clock in the morning in
general it was on different now but
generally 10 in the morning 10 to 11 an
hour it could be anybody you know it
could be gore vidal if you had here one
of my favorite guests or writers so it
could be
uh peggy terry an appalachian woman
speaking for the appalachians of chicago
could be uh
alfred brendell the pianist could be
dizzy gillespie
big bill my hair jack anybody you know
portland oregon you're next
hi um i have a question about the book
working i'm going through a transition
in my life both
trying to decide if i should go back to
work for corporate america after being a
small business person and i'm also
getting divorced and i have to say
oh i hope i marry a man someday like you
because what you said about your wife
was wonderful but as far as your books
and transition for people that are
looking from
going to one job to another do you think
working is what you would recommend or
is there another book
and get that last part
for transition people um
what book would you recommend
of one of my books yeah what all depends
for the depression hard times what was
it like
working what is your job like
whether it be housewife or whether it be
businessman or or a welder at an auto
plant or a car dealer or a model what is
your work like uh race well races what
is it like to be black one guy says this
joe lattimore his name is uh
african-american guys well i was on an
fm a lot of older black people chicago
know me the young kids don't know but i
was on this african-american station
wvon voice of the negroes and i i'm
talking to them they know me a lot of
new isis i'm doing this book now
don't you go crazy if you wake up in the
morning thinking about being black in a
white america does it drive you nuts
and he says we are crazy but so were you
you're crazier you see so that that's
why i called up the american obsession
it's the obsession meaning it's you're
nuts
and he says the black is like wearing
tight shoes
shoes are too tight you don't complain
some guys adjust to it okay because
others don't they're complaining about
it so i love that analogy like wearing
shoes out of two
i pulled this quote actually
frameworking it's from william faulconer
you can't eat for eight hours a day nor
drink for eight hours a day nor make
love for eight hours a day all you can
do is work eight hours which is the
reason why man makes himself and
everybody else so miserable and unhappy
that was william faulkner and that's in
the epigraph in the beginning i used
that you know
and one is about anderson
and then on the epigraph another one i
used also an advertising ad
for french
but that's interesting
uh f walker being ironic of course
about eight hours a day
eight
well now
and that's another thing by the way i'm
glad you raised that
eight hours a day
uh many young people are anti-union
anti-labor now these wonderful young
people you know who were
coming small colleges who were fighting
the sweatshop conditions of third world
guns were nike shoes and all that
and these young kids in seattle got
together with labor guys
but a great many young people don't know
about
trade unions they're anti so i'll tell
this anecdote do you mind it's because
sometimes an anecdote is telling it's
funny and it's 95 percent true
and this anecdote
is
i talk a lot i so i'm known in the
neighborhood where i live as the
garrulous old guy who's written a couple
of books and who's they see on radio or
tv they know me and but this one couple
i'm also egotistical this one couple on
the corner where i wait for the bus
which one for you ignore me completely i
talked ignore me a very handsome couple
he's right out of gentleman's quarterly
a three-piece suit uh wall street
journal in his hand and she's a looker i
mean
a looker you know uh neiman marcus
closed bloomingdale she's got vanity
fair under arm but i can't crack him and
so the bus is late and come on that day
and so i holler out labor day is coming
up
that was the wrong thing to say because
he turns at me with a look of noel
coward looking at a speck of dirt and a
cuff like that he turns back and says oh
i'm hurt my ego really hurt so now now
the imp of the perverse has been on my
hip so i'm saying something who's going
to get a mad so i see you labor day we
used to march down state street chicago
down michigan boulevard uaw cio banners
flying packing us works with america
we'd sing solidarity with sadion and we
shall not be moved and he turns storming
the voice of ice he says we despise
unions turns back i said oh
i got a pigeon here you know the bus is
late so now i'm the ancient mariner
and i fix it with my glittering eye and
i say how many hours a day do you work
and he's caught unawares by the
non-sequitur he says eight eight how
come you don't work 18 hours a day your
great-grandparents worked eight you know
why you were eight not eighteen because
in chicago
four guys were hanged
fighting for the 1886 the haymarket
thing i bring up everything you know in
1886 the haymarket affair four of these
german anarchists were hanged fighting
for the eight-hour day for you and i got
him pinned against the mailbox now he
can't get away you see and the bus is
getting coming now he's a little
troubling against his old nut you know
and she drops the
vanity fair and i'm pretty courtney
matter pick it up and hand it to her and
then i say how many hours a week do you
work and he says
hey uh 40. how come you don't work 80
hours a week they did your great great
you know why because people in the 30s
got their heads busted and blacked
fighting for the 40-hour week for you by
this time they get back on the bus
i never saw him again but i'll bet to
this day they deliver this condo
upscale condo facing the bus stop but
she's looking out that window every
morning on the 25th floor and he's
saying is that old nuts still down there
well
i don't blame them how do they know what
do we know about the we have a business
section in the papers op-ed business
sports style gossip
we don't have a labor section no of
course not normally no
so how would they know these things
that's what i mean by history what the
depression was all about and what
everything else is all about and so
another email from tommy flippo jr of
arkansas studs terkel
what writer influenced you the most i'm
sorry what writer influenced you the
most what right do i like the most oh
that's a hard one
so it all depends novelis
i like dom dalilo
very much like doctoral i like uh nelson
organ always
i like the writing we're talking about
writing i like the gore vidal and i like
gary wills for their all-around
knowledge
and but what writers
there yeah
russell banks a wonderful young american
novelist who says he wouldn't have been
a novelist work not for nelson logan i
like kurt vonnegut of course he got
tremendous kick out of him he by the way
is in this book this death book
and it's very funny
atlanta next caller go ahead please
uh yes mr turkle it's a great pleasure
uh talking to a national treasure um and
i have a couple of quick questions um
you would mention the fact that uh
about speaking for the voiceless um who
today who of the journalists and writers
today give voice to the voiceless um
who are the mike roy clothes who are who
are the edward r murrows
those like yourself and also you
mentioned you invoke the the memory of a
reference to 1984.
is it not that would you make it also a
reference to brave new world and that we
have become complicit with the
lobotomization of the culture um maybe
you could address these two points
well you mean we're talking about
which of the writers have we today well
they're around and about there's so many
young writers who are good you know
historians of course there's a
howard zinn does a bottom-up thing it's
going to be an hbo i think so in a
series bottom-up history
i like that
uh there are all kinds of journalists
around doing good stuff
i can't think of any particular one at
the moment but they're they're around
here and there they got a chance to the
only trouble is
the newspapers themselves you know are
more and more
with fewer and fewer and then we have tv
the role of tv we have the same pundits
the same
we know who they are you you know their
mediocrities they didn't know wiser than
we are if anything i think the average
person knows as much as they do but
we're fed this every day and they avoid
the talking heads
now and then someone unique appears my
god that's a delight
but around and about you have these
writers
one form or another who are good who do
their best in some of the alternative
magazines like the nation or in these
times and magazines of that sort
and so people have to i think start
thinking for themselves it has to be a
grass root thing by the way on the
subject of war we know there's since
broken's greatest generation a phrase i
dislike by the way not the greatest the
one i'm part of not the greatest
generation it was a generation that's
good no better than this generation but
it happened to live at a certain two key
moments in american history the
depression and world war ii
and the two phenomena are related you
can't have one without the other and so
the good war
is in quotes that's key
the good war you know hermet gang of the
new york times one said uh in contrast
to vietnam anything is good countries
that maladventure of ours but uh the
good wars world war ii of course war
against fascism
and it's a good war but
good and war don't match my my wife who
said instead you've got to put that in
quotes
the good war
because no such thing as a good war
even world war ii
because the kid next door became a
savage especially the pacific theater
you know and
why does a kid do these heroic things
not for flag for country for apple he
does it for the kid next to him doesn't
let that kid down so he does these
heroic things but to what to kill a
stranger
to kill a stranger
and so
movie oh you know all quite a western
front that early film with the young
german soldier louis played it is in the
trench and he stabs the french foil
and he's fighting and then suddenly sees
the guy looking bewildered at him he
takes out the wallet and there's the
wife and then this happens pacific there
elsewhere the japanese guy they take out
the wallet and he's wow
that's his wife that's his kids
so the good war good and war
the noun adjectives do not match they're
in congress and so not talking about
vietnam or the gulf war those
obscenities
and their obscenities of course
san diego you're next with studs terkel
on book tvs in depth
hi studs love all your books i wanted to
ask you if in all the many years you've
interviewed people have you been able to
figure out
um
what is
what have you figured out about human
nature oh boy and what what motivates
and drives people to to even get out of
bed in the morning when
we face such a tough and complex world
even more so than really when you were
growing up
what have you figured out about
human nature what what makes us what
drives it that's an awfully good
question i'm glad you asked it i'm also
sorry you're asking because i really
can't answer it the fact is i find out
and will come to that story of mine in a
moment that they're complex even those
of whom you disagree completely
as a complexity here there's a
contradiction what makes shakespeare so
great
what makes shakespeare like no
playwright ever the history of the human
species is his understanding even though
wrote an elizabethan times his
understanding of the human being whether
it be not just hamlet everybody
what made corey elena's do what he did
what made but hamlet of course what made
lear this
old man is he stupid is he that what
the the contradictions in people's
nature
and i discovered that among the great
many
and as a good case in point
i'm glad you asked now it brings back
this you don't mind this free
association the stream of consciousness
he raised that question i was
interviewing appalachian couple in
chicago you know chicago was the home
for many as well as african-american
sharecroppers to come to chicago from
the deep south steel was on the packing
house workers stockyards and uh
farm equipment workers and appalachians
came to
to chicago from tennessee and kentucky
and so i'm interviewing this appalachian
couple in this community and i'm leaving
and it's raining
and luckily a cab comes along and those
days they had a heavy ewer tape under my
arm
a strap you or not i carry a small sony
a viewer and uh the cab driver young guy
young white guy says uh are you a
journalist or something i said well sort
of you know he says did you see the
movie lord jim he's talking about joe
for joseph conrad's novel the movie with
peter o'toole i said yeah he says well
that's a movie's about me
about himself i said what do you mean
about you he says well i was a coward
and i did an act of courage finally
that's why i joined the john birch
society i said oh
boy i gotta get this guy you know so i
tell him what i do he said sure i'll
talk to you so here's a guy who's john
birch society for those who may not know
his arch arch arch to the right you know
anybody's a red who disagrees and he'll
kill lamar for that at the same time the
same guy
is saying he was a guard in the prison
and they fired him because he's
fraternizing with the inmates most of
whom were black and what do you mean by
fraternizing well it's one guy it's
about me black guy in prison what time
is it and i said why you know hurry they
got a plane to catch and suddenly why
are you doing that to this man
he's in prison he went to apologize to
him and he really says you know
i think
i trust black people more than i do
white people the same guy john birch
yeah and you know what
and then florence scala one of my
heroines in the book the very first
woman i interviewed first person for the
first book division street of the old
history
tried to savor a community
from being torn down by the mayor in the
cement lobby it was called harrison and
horst a colorful wonderful community
into
multicultural wonderful they tore it
down she tried well florence ran for
alderman against the machine you know
where key backer was this guy
so you see the kind the conflict within
him he wants to be somebody
and so we can join something perversely
you see there are a lot of people who
want to talk to you which will lead of
course to that big one quickly though
how do you know when you've done an
interview that works that's how do i
know what works i don't know that's
that's good one you just it's that
tingle
that's something
sometimes you can tell you can't uh
sometimes interviews don't go
but i've lost many i mean the my
big regret is cutting people out who are
so good
and have second thoughts about them in
all the books especially in this
forthcoming one they gave me their time
they gave me their
experiences
you know
bingo
and with tommy gates the fireman he's
just a natural-born storyteller he opens
this book as he closed working
but this matter because this question
that he asked leads to the big one
i'm always asked what is the one if
there's one interview you could choose
what is the one you would choose some
would say you once interviewed and you
would bertrand russell during the cuban
missile crisis of 1963
i went to his uh home in north wales in
the village it was a great interview but
that wasn't the one i remember
i was in apartheid south africa
in 6263
interviewing the predecessor of nelson
mandela chief albert john lituri
uh
julia chieftain
who's head of the african national
congress while mandela was still in
robin island prison
and that was in
and there was a
suburb of stingers where uh a suburb of
durban where mahatma gandhi young mahapa
gandhi practiced law
and in the suburb and with this man who
was fantastic but that's not the
greatest the greatest was with c p ellis
former grand cyclops of the ku klux klan
of durham north carolina i read
somewhere about claiborne ellis
and
a black woman
and atwater
traveling the country
campaigning advocating unions for
janitors custodial unions i said i gotta
get this guy
x x
grand cyclops
ex-clan
and i finally get him and he tells me
the story
he's a poor white
his life has been rotten he's a [ __ ]
kid who he loves
and he tries a milk rod it fails the gas
station fails he remembers a 50 gallon
tank to heat this trailer home
one gallon a week you could buy is that
drip drip drip that's my life
somebody's to blame for this it's got to
be a [ __ ] because that's what he taught
all his life you see if your life is
miserable
you can't get there's got to be somebody
you're going to be told somebody less
than you below you and of course that's
the black
and he's been taught this
now at that same time there's a woman in
town a man
who's an african-american woman who's a
large woman who's ill a lot of time but
she's leading it's the civil rights time
now leading the picket lines to get
department stores of durham to hire
black clerks
and he'd break up those picket lines
he'd hired you get these young kids
thought about that they break and it was
but i mean it was it was
rough at the same time jimmy carter is
now president
and
hud h.u.d sends a couple of million
bucks to durham for the school system
for charette's adult library
and so the schools are segregated black
and white but this committee for some
reason or others integrated the
committee there
and as a black guy the committee says
i got an idea i'm gonna let's invite
every parent of every student attending
every public school in durham she
invites the kkk as well as the naacp
he invites the white citizens council as
well as snick as well as his
southern
conference the martin luther king group
so cp says i'm going to go to that thing
and especially are you crazy with them
yeah she meaning that well she's got a
girl going to school i got a boy going
to school you want i'd represent the
girl i mean that not everything now that
millions there
he went for i want my kid represented so
of course they're at it they're there
and they're at it he gets up to say his
say what he is and they call each other
racists and finally somebody says can't
go on this where we've got to have a
committee sometimes i nominate ann
atwater as chair of the committee and
this black guy gets and i nominate cpl
as his co-chair i think he's an honest
man at that moment i'm gonna see if he's
talking to me
what'd he call me an honest guy this
black is calling me an honest
hey what's he trying to do to me to turn
my life upside down or something it's
getting kind of funny and he said we
agree he and ann agree they don't like
each other but they got she's got a girl
he's got a boy so they meet and now as
he's talking to me i notice he's saying
ann said this
and did that and i wonder ann comes into
crying what you're crying about he's for
the kids at the school the black school
i'm mocking her
you know
buking and scoring her as the spiritual
goes because her mother's going around
with a clansmen
and he sees crying suddenly
he says that's happened to my boy in the
white school
they love sticks and stones at him
because his father's going out with this
black woman agitator and suddenly
they're clinging to one another and then
the same boat
in the meantime little epiphanies are
recurring to him
he used to get calls at night
big shots in town when he broke up those
picket lines you're fantastic cp keep
doing it great there's one day i'm
walking down the street in the big shots
walking toward me
and he sees me
and he crosses over to the other side of
the street
wait a minute wait a minute
am i being had am i being used
and then i see a black guy going by he's
as raggedy as i am is he responsible
bit by bit this is happening and now
he's got a job as a janitor at duke
university because duke is in durham
janet a custodian which is mostly black
he's one of the few whites mostly women
and
they're organizing a union suddenly he
realizes he's pretty good at this he
gets people to sign cards suddenly you
realize his calling
union target labor organizer he's good
at he's going to run for full-time job
business agent of this local or the
regional thing against the black he's
not going to win because it's 80 percent
blackman so he gets up to make his
speech he said you know who i am you
know what and the women will say sit
downs we know who you are because the
company sent out this leaflet with him
on robes
i forgot to tell you
he told way back i forgot the big thing
how he joined the clan
we'll come back to that see he's now
poor white but joined the clan they put
the hood on them they put the robe on
them
and and and he you can't believe me a
poor white nothing trash and you got
illuminated semi-illuminated
hall
walking toward that illuminated cross
i felt like i was somebody when he said
i felt like i was somebody it exploded
in my head at jesse jackson talking
operation push you are somebody meaning
you have some self-esteem whereas in
this case being somebody at the expense
of somebody so that's the early part you
remember that and i joined and got me
joining the clan women to sit down we
know where you are when he wants me so
he's expect to lose he's they've elected
me three to one
something like that's when he remember
he had a hard job
not crying he said those women knew me
they knew my heart they voted for me
and now she says me and those women
we've had little education he got a ged
we have five fifth grade education but
you know you know what that company
sends in with princeton lawyers yeah
lawyers the ghost they can't out
negotiate us being those women now i
feel like i'm somebody
and that's what i call scripturalness
power
and so that's my favorite interview
give me hope washington dc go ahead
mr turkle it's an honor and a pleasure
um i have a
personal anecdote and
a tribute
my father was a lifelong labor lawyer
and organizer always working on the side
of the worker
he was the son of immigrants a brooklyn
boy and wound up organizing cotton
workers in biloxi and then wound up
working at the national labor relations
board
he died when i was quite young when i
was 14 and it was really before i had
any
intellectual curiosity or any real
knowledge about what it was that he had
devoted his life to
and years later when i was in new york
and working at nyu
someone gave me a copy of your book
working
and it was reading that book
that was
an epiphany for me personally it was not
only the beginning of what became a
passion for the history of labor law in
the united states that i've stuck with
but it also became the beginning of
going back
and being able to personally connect
with
my father's passion after he was gone
and i owe you a great debt of thanks and
um keep doing what you're doing
thank you very much marie
thank you
addison illinois you're next hello mr
turkle i was wondering if you could give
me your opinion regarding your book the
good war why president roosevelt did not
go in sooner and recognize what was
going on in the concentration camps and
why he never ordered bombing of the
concentration camps when it's clear he
did have some indication of what was
going on thank you very much i wish i
could answer that i can't it's true that
many flaws you know in fdr
uh he was my favorite president of
course not even close to at the same
time many flaws and remember it was also
bottom-up demonstrations that led to
some of the moves like there would have
been no it wasn't
fair employment practices act that fdi
was for because he was afraid of the
dixiecrats down south hey philip
randolph threatened to lead a march and
that was part of it so it was about as
far as that that's one of the flaws in
his campaign for that matter the
internment of the japanese americans and
they say it's a shameful period of
course that too was part of it so many
of the young nisei kids says they're not
wild about fdr
and not nisei the kids are sansei and
the niece accepted their lot you know
and in fact it was the american friends
service committee a group that has
always been right the quakers who have
been fantastic who urged
the japanese americans on the west coast
denise that is the second generation to
resist
because they arrest a couple hundred
thousand whatever their people
they didn't they said mind your own
business so it's the sun say the kids of
those in concentration camps are the
ones who have uncovered all this and
done it so back to the
holocaust and the concentration camps
turning back that ship to
that jews escaping hitler is uh i'm
afraid of
deep deep flaws remember there was a
state department there that was
with
uh along his name is breckenridge long
and others who was uh
patently i mean obviously anti-semitic
of course great deal of that so
that's part of the history i'm afraid
this is the 12th in a series of in-depth
interviews here on book tv our guest is
studs turkle our next call sacramento go
ahead please
good morning to both of you and of
course especially to mr turkle
i wanted to ask you about a couple of
your contemporaries mr turkle but before
i do i want to
thank you with as much sincerity as i
can muster for your comments just a few
minutes ago the list the difference
between world war ii and
vietnam
vietnam
as a vietnam veteran i i possess a
measure of resentment against many of
your generation
uh that i had a hard time convincing
that it was an accident of birth that
they got world war ii and i got vietnam
and
i can't thank you enough for for your
comments and your understanding uh the
two contemporaries i wanted to ask you
about was did you know eric hoffer and
saul alinsky and what did you think of
both of them well i didn't know eric
hoffer though i i know i knew solenski
very well from chicago and he of course
is the pioneer of the matter of
community organization
remember he always felt self-interest is
very important and he'd call upon that
very often the word he used the key word
was do an action
action he used as a noun and as a verb
and uh he was able to
his secret of organizing was to make
it clear to people to your personal
interest that you work in the community
as you do it so and of course this book
is a bible of people a revelry for
radicals is the book i knew soul very
well
uh
i know they were friends he and huffer
but i didn't know hoffer too well though
but
he's one of he still has
his stuff is still going on uh
solinsky's stuff
big ed chambers in chicago it's called
industrial areas foundation the official
name of what he does and he goes on in
certain cities here and there
do things
he's known for a very funny thing he was
organizing a group in rochester
and uh the rochester symphony that i
think that's kodak town but also the
symphony
uh and so
the black people uh there were he i
think was a group called fight or
something like he organized and he had
to get something to embarrass sometimes
they have people go to the home of the
actual person
picking it outside to make it close to
the person in this case he fed the
people a lot of beans a lot of beans a
lot of beans for the symphony and you
know what happened during the symphony
well stuff like that or remember mary
lou wolf was a disciple of his would do
the same thing when the governor
wouldn't do anything for them uh she'd
they bring the kids with lollipops and
taffy apples they knew this in swedish
designed furniture because of taffy
apples and lollipops were just doing
things they finally had to agree to see
him and so
that's part of his technique as well
goose creek south carolina you're next
hey uh hello mr turco
hello i'm with you oh yeah i'm one of
your one of your fans
and i'm ex-marine and i read about and i
read in one of your books are called a
good war
that you made a statement
and me being an ex-marine i just
couldn't understand it you said during
the second world war a lot of the
marines who stole the beaches in the
south pacific were
part of expression homosexual and i just
couldn't understand that
i don't know if you made a mistake or oh
no no there were all on the contrary
there were many homosexuals in the
marines but the boys wanted to show that
they were heroic do something they were
fear they didn't did they remember they
didn't come out of the closet they did
today but of course there were
the many humans and there were heroes
and quite wonderful one man in the book
i called him
his name was george busey real name he
died recently he's a wonderful man
ted allenby he's in the book that's the
man you're referring to but of course
they were
and because they were punished you know
and demoted and humiliated
and some assaulted
were they heroes of course they were
heroes if something was them were
superheroes to prove that they were
manly
it wasn't a mistake at all on the
contrary
studs turkle born in new york in 1912
you were
what age when you moved to chicago well
i'm sorry how old were you when you
moved to chicago
eight nineteen twenty warren harding
just time warren harding was elected
president warning the mayor larding and
it was 1920. just about
december of 1920 i was eight years old
go to the rooming house this room had my
mother around her father was ill he and
i would share the crystal set together
this crystal radio set crystal set a
little wired and we've got certain radio
stations and hear your voice wendell
hall the red-headed music maker singing
a song called lincoln rain no more no
more how the heck you're going to wash
your neck when ain't going to rain no
more
we heard the scopes trial you know the
monkey trial on wgn chicago
part of it my mother ran it you know she
was very much my mother was very much
like she was a tough little sparrow very
much like thomas wolfe's mother in the
coming angel when i read lacombe with
angel i flipped i was
17 19 2018
1930 when i read it and
his mother in asheville north carolina
which called altamonte in the book ran a
boarding house her name was eliza eliza
gant in the book my mother's name was
annie and she ran a room
i associated the two they're very
similar
tough little sparrows
san diego with studs turkle you're next
okay
go ahead caller
hello i'm with you
yes uh my name is uh lester i want to
comment on
the chicago globetrotters on the south
side at the savoy theater you remember
that
at the survivor the globetrotters you
say no yes
you mean the basketball team yeah the
original harlem globetrotters oh yeah
originated from this and abe saperstein
ran them yeah well you know they were
great basketball players you know to be
clowns on the basketball field to be a
clown you have to be a craftsman
you know and there were great crafters
they could clown you know wc fields for
example was a great juggler you know
really he was a great juggler and so
when he do that stuff kicked that
thing piece of paper behind him he was
juggling
he'd make a comical thing out of it and
so they made comedy out of their art but
they mastered the art first so the
globetrotters are known for that
next call from tear free arizona you're
on book tv hey i know that you're just
sitting there
uh most anxious for somebody to bring up
jazz and i'm doing it so talk about jazz
and freedom if you would jazz and
freedom well the freest form there is i
remember what
jasmine could do whether it be armstrong
who created a revolution and when he was
playing west end blue in fact did you
see the ken burns
series i'm talking a listener
you saw that series yes remember that
west end blues that was my theme song
for years on this program i told you
about wfmt i'd open and close with that
because rather than something out of
beethoven's ninth which you had in mind
because in west end blues you have
something incredible happening he's
praying that trump has never played and
they then he starts scat singing and so
it's hard until the trumpet left off and
the voice began
both were voices
of the band and so jazz has that sort of
improvisatory freedom that we love to
have on our show called studs place in a
way our three programs gatheraways and
bertilson's cuckola and such place were
jazzy programs
in that there was room for improvisation
and so that's freedom of course
you dedicated the book to john llewellyn
john llewellyn died long ago john
llewellyn
was producing the mahalia jackson
program
when i was the emcee
and john died of leukemia
way back
and he's the one suggested
do something about jazz
and so i dedicate the book to john
llewellyn
salt st paul minnesota you're next
hello i'm with you
um yes i'd like to know what your
thoughts are about organized labor today
compared to 50 years ago
well as you know it's taken a hell of a
beating
since reagan and it's coming back you
know but we'll come to that in a minute
uh you know we have new constituencies
the service employees union for example
has women and third world people that's
the biggest fastest growing organization
there is service employees but we always
have industrial unions now one of the
key moments i think when labor tickets
were speeding was the first act
of ronald reagan in office in 1981 have
elected 1980 1981 when he broke the air
controller's strike i'm glad you raised
that remember the air controllers strike
he broke the union which by the way was
a conservative union air controllers
union voted overwhelmingly for ronald
reagan
and he broke the union and broke the
strike and four to five americans
applauded ronnie you're great what was
the strike about wasn't wages it was
about passenger safety
we see every day the air controller in
his hands of the fate of thousands of
americans each day scores of thousands
each day and so not just nerve-wracking
work and they were campaigning for rest
and recreation
for uh
care for
psychiatric care for sanatoria for the
various things that would enable them to
be more efficient nothing to save lives
so
the strike was for passenger safety and
four to five americans applauded ronnie
for breaking that strike so i have to
think have we become a necrophilic
people do we love death are we caughting
death perhaps we are and i'm saying this
furiously and angrily at this moment and
also i'm being sarcastic and sardonic i
hope
so that's the question since that time
and eleven thousand were blacklisted and
we weren't worried about unseasoned air
controllers and near misses and you said
i mean don't we have any thought at all
and so as a result of that many of the
young
it didn't start with him but there's his
whole
also labor itself the labor skates such
as george meany and lane kirkland were
just bookkeepers they were going along
with management but the labor management
deals were sweetheart deals ever since
then it took a beating see john l lewis
had something else in mind and those
people who were kicked out of unions had
something else in mind rank and there
was not enough rank and file and that's
the big thing just as we need grassroots
we need more rank and file intake and
these new unions i think the service
employees union is a hopeful one indeed
lake tahoe nevada
good afternoon yeah good afternoon uh
studs i was curious to see uh if you
ever read any of the uh
writings of ann rand and what do you
think of her as a writer
of who ann rand
oh boy oh boy well i think ryan rand as
a writer unbelievable
iron
you know alan greenspan is a disciple of
vine rand you know that i should tell
you all you need to know iron man is one
of these if i got it by god it's mine
never mind that and no matter how about
the rest you know she has other contempt
for the masses that she calls it she has
the slightest idea what it's about to me
she's a clown figure and you find young
kids reading her book the fountainhead
atlas shrugged i can tell i think you'd
read in the book i said is that the
fountainhead
yeah how did you know i said oh geez how
do i know
and so
this is
unbelievable i mean she's she's a comic
figure i think this thing called
objectivism and alan greenspan is one of
her disciples
so that should tell you whom he favors
as it goes along see i don't know what
it takes but ein rand is really
something
she by the way is one of the writers
that we are featuring all year long on
our american writer series you can go to
the website for more information
americanwriters.org wabash indiana good
afternoon with studs terkel
hi mr truecall yes sir i'm excited to be
on uh i'm i've recently been a bob
become a bob dylan fan
and i'm reading an autobiography about
him and i understand that in 60 or 61
the early 60s you did an interview with
him in chicago who was that bob dylan
oh yeah i did one bob dylan yeah it was
okay i wasn't too wild about it
but it was a good interview yeah uh
that's the first time i met him i knew
his manager a guy named al grossman any
nice place called the gate of horn in
chicago when bob was in town it was the
first interview i think he's ever had
yeah
and so
interesting fascinating but i was not
maybe i wasn't up on it enough i'm not
sure if it was okay
it'll i'm clearly getting the next book
book called
next book i like that i'm 88.
anyway in a book called the listener i
finish a book called the spectator which
is about my interest theater
and in movies certain artists i like
whether it be tennessee williams or
buster keaton
or zero mostel i think
i'll show it to our audience and get a
call from chicago go ahead please
hi mr turkle i had a question about what
you said earlier about being an atheist
and
i would like to know your thoughts on
the spread of christianity
amongst americans
and what you thought about
the strong belief of christianity
emerging in the youngsters of today did
you say the threat of christianity bread
of christianity
i think but explain that to me i didn't
quite hear that caller is still on the
air uh i was wondering about what you
thought about the spread of christianity
or the spread of christianity among
where amongst the american youngsters in
america oh well i think anything a
person believes and if it gives them
solace or gives them thought or enriches
their lives i'm for i don't care what
it's called you know but you mean the
christian coalition of the right you're
talking about that yeah especially
because it seems like a very fanatical
it's emerging into a more of a fanatical
thought
process and i i was just curious to see
what you thought about that well i think
that the coalition the christian court
is the right of something else that's
not christianity it's the opposite of
christianity christianity is
sermon on the mount christianity is love
thy neighbor
christianity is
let the suffering come unto me
you know uh for those who say i'm it and
uh the others are pagans and heathens
and antichrists well that's something
else that's antichrist that's the real
antichrist you see
denver colorado europe tv
uh good morning mr turkle yes sir uh i
just wanted to tell you that i years ago
grew up in uh chicago and you had
mentioned um goldman sachs earlier in
the program
that's where i had my first job at
goldman sachs i was a messenger
in 1959 that you may recall that was the
field building at 135 south lasalle
street
and jack dempsey had an office in that
building and i used to see him in the
elevator and that was a heck of a thrill
for a 16 year old to see that to be able
to see the champ
that's great jack dempsey it brings back
memories of course that was a famous
dempsey tony fight the big event that
soldier field in chicago 19
was it 27
1927 i think
16 count that's a long story for sports
fans
long island new york good afternoon
good afternoon
mr tarko yes sir um
i was interested in comments about the
rank and file in labor and i was
wondering what your thoughts are
on america forming a labor party
as uh england has and canada has we've
never had an american
labor political party and i was
wondering if you had any thoughts on
that well you see the formation of the
british labor party was came about
because of bernard shaw for one thing uh
keira hardy and there were whole there
was there was the conservative party and
the liberal party and there was a big
gap there
ours
a labor party there there is a labor
party there's a green party there are
too many there has to be a coalition
party involving labor and the
environmental people and the young i
think we need
we have too many third parties and
that's the trouble i think we need one
big tent to recognize that at this
moment the two major parties but they're
it's not quite right either it's in the
democratic party has a progressive
caucus
that i find very interesting and very
fascinating
dennis dennis kucinich the young
alderman from cleveland former boy mayor
who single-handedly held off the private
interest from taking over the utilities
claimed that municipal the online
utilities is now a congressman he jan
schakowsky chicago and and jesse jackson
jr uh there's a whole coalition they've
got to take over the democratic party
with the help of all these other people
who would form these other parties but
uh as it is right now at the hands of
the democratic leadership council
so-called who go more and more to the
center link clinton started that more
and more to the center that you can't
tell the difference at times there is a
big difference of course now but the
fact is
that's got to be taken out of their
hands and this whole progressive caucus
has to take it over with the help of all
those other nato rights and all the
others have to be part of it so labor
party alone won't quite do it that might
be its ultimate name but can some other
name but
it has to be that populist
overflow it should be one big tent i'm
considered
and there are enough people for that i
think los angeles
yes i was wondering uh you were born in
the last year of president taft's
administration i was wondering if you
could speak from your unique perspective
about the life the last years of
president taft who of course became the
chief justice um
and apparently he was a very well-loved
man he was a very much progressive uh in
although oftentimes thought of as a
conservative i was wondering your your
unique view of history if you could
speak about that i'd appreciate it we've
got justice who william howard taft
president and well done too much about
taft
uh i knew he was a heavy man
but
but i
my favorite
justices of course were william douglas
and hugo black and
they were in walter brennan not walter
brennan
i won't run
justice brennan they were more
i think they represented the strong
dissent and for that matter the warren
court was a glorious moment
when
you know the the
affirmative action when that when when
the school system when you know brown
versus board was a key moment that was a
key high moment since then there's been
a declaration but i think what the five
justices have done to made a mockery the
five justices who said no more
accounting and interpreting offense in
in effect elected w as president i would
say
they have in fact justice stevens my
friend one i quote he says you can
hardly take the court seriously anymore
so i would say that's a big moment but
there's certain key members
of my respect very much brennan black
douglas
stevens for that matter email from kevin
smith from chicago last year i heard a
rebroadcast of an interview that you did
with james baldwin in 1961 the year
before i was born he talked mostly about
race relations in america i was in
complete shock because it was as a as if
the interview was taking place today
it is that's an interesting comment uh
we have changes of course for the better
however so much remains james baldwin
nobody knows my name the title should
say at all but i know yours because you
know the servant was not there
and
it is
here we go again
you know the the sabotaging of
affirmative action
well
w of course but california doing it you
know what's happened to the students the
the enrollment of students in law school
and medical school of black students
gone down precipitously you see it's
unbelievable
and so i'm glad she said that that's
true it's as though that's what i meant
by a national alzheimer's disease no
memory of yesterday or someone would say
amnesia we're amnesiacs you know are we
we have to know and one of the things
about the good war and the depression
book is that to know what was it like
what's it like to be a certain person at
a certain time in our history see
what was it like to be that person quad
cities alabama you're next with studs
turkle
yes
do you remember sanibel island and how
often have you visited there you you
autographed my division street book uh a
delightful remembrance of the tropics in
the early seventies yeah we're visiting
where i like your i like the enthusiasm
and the power of your voice but i didn't
get the where sanibel island florida
island i'm not an outdoorsman i must
point out that i cut my feet with all
those seashells you know sandoval had
the seashells and i was cutting my feet
all the time i'm an indoorsman you know
you know a robert maynard hutchins said
the former chancellor was chicago
whenever i feel the urge for exercise i
lie down until it passes over and so i
wasn't i liked sanibel islands
i did except that i cut my feet we got a
call from north carolina go ahead please
hi studs yeah
my name is john from uh
rhode island
[Music]
yes sir i'm interested in organized
crime and the reason why uh the fbi and
uh james whitey bulger or there are a
lot of interaction between the fbi and
james whitey bulger i'd like to know a
little bit more about it whether or not
they were just protecting him all this
time just for information
if you have any knowledge please feel
free to
fbi and who
james white
whose brother by the way is the
president of
boston college i believe oh yeah well
you know it's interesting you raised
that point john edgar hoover you know
was not exactly enemy of organized crime
i mean he was taken over of
after organized teachers
he was taken over after the surreal
subversives you know those were called
reds and pinkos and that was his big
mission in fact he was easy on organized
crime quite frankly now remember i once
almost worked for the fbi as a
fingerprint classifier this was just
after law school looking for a job and
fingerprint classifier is something
you've just classified i think
paid 1260 a year i think
and so i used to write letters and
johnny hoover that is whoever has
replied i never got the job
but back to that i was interviewed man
named melvin purvis who was head of the
chicago bureau of fbi he's one who was
responsible for the capture the killing
of john dillinger and hoover was very
envious
he hated purvis because purpose is
making the headlines hoover was the
headline grabbers all he was and he was
a buddy of walter winchell you know and
hoover much deserved to have a building
name after him as as pharaoh does you
know and in any event
not too hard an organized crime i'd say
arlington virginia yes my name is becky
forgive my voice have a cold
mr turkle i've read the good war
um at least three times um have learned
so much about it i was born in 1966 and
i think as many people my generation
probably felt a great separation from
the events of the first half of the
century you know world war ii happened
in black and white
and in my high school education we
frankly never even studied world war ii
we got to it
and found out we want it and that's just
about it
what do you feel about you know reading
the good war got me much more interested
in those events and
a lot more aware of the things that
were so important that happened this
century let's steve let's say repeat
that to me it's my uh something went cox
she she basically is a fan of the good
war she was the one in 1966 this book
the good war yeah what about it
call you still with us
what did you want to know about it you
were praising the book did you have a
question about the book yes i'm
i've learned so much more about world
war ii
from your book than i ever did
in
my you know school education oh well i'm
glad well
i mean
i'm i'm happy to hear that you see
that's what i was hoping is in other
words that is specific you see
every moment in that is specific whether
it's the boy or the girl or the woman
having a job for the first time in her
life she's left the kitchen you know to
work in the defense plants after germany
invaded poland in 1939 that's when the
depression really ended there's no
question new deal and wpa and all the
other athletes saved american lives the
theme of millions but didn't quite end
it there were 11 million unemployed then
came the war and the defense and so
i'm glad you felt that about the book
it's just what is it like to be that
person in that prison camp or to be that
woman in england and when the blitz
occurs or to be that german soldier
what is it like to be that person or to
be the gi a mama's boy and a landing
craft just about to hit normandy you
know what's it like
you see and so
that is why well i aim for so when you
said you learned more from that than
from others i'm delighted to hear you
say that
next call for studs turkle is from fort
myers florida
uh yeah gosh i might have stood i could
i could sit here all day and listen to
you but if you came down to sanibel
island now you wouldn't cut your feet on
any shelves because the tourists took
those out of here about 25 years ago
but let me talk about another great
divide
stud
i'm looking here at a federal reserve
charts
and it shows who owns how much of what
and the total distribution of wealth
in america
one percent of the people on 38 percent
of the wealth
and another nine percent on 32 percent
making the top 10 percent of americans
of american wealth being controlled
controlling 70 percent of the wealth and
i'd just like to hear your comments on
that divide and what it does to
democracy oh boy you've just said it of
course you've said it you've you he has
just produced the figures imagine what
that does
now you are cut to the world of course
but to ourselves think of what that does
to the world but to ourselves to the
other and now of course the way it is in
till 2002 i hope there's a turnover
somewhere here
think of what it does
the very fact that
w i call him w i can't say president i'm
sorry i just cannot accept that because
it was stolen of course it was but w
says
his tax is going to reward that 10
percent more so than ever well if
they're rewarded somebody has to pay for
it and so that
90 percent pays for it and so this is
unbelievable that we even dream of
accepting it and taking him seriously
and so we this now goes for the pundits
and the papers and the editorials they
we must be polite we must know we must
not be polite american revolution wasn't
polite at all
we must say this is wrong absolutely and
challenge us all the way through and
that's why the democratic party right
now seems to be in shambles now where's
i thought they're really going to jump
when he named ashworth as attorney
general it's unbelievable you know and
he goes on and on and on and continues
it's not that he's a bad man he's
mindless utterly mindless but he's happy
his advisers say this is the way it is
we'll knock the hell out of environment
we'll knock the hell out of this we'll
do the taxes so it'll help the top one
percent more he's not deliberately
saying that but it's doing it
and of course you you've pointed out the
disparity that is astonishing of course
back to your books talking to myself yes
sir
what's it about well i'm talking to
myself instead of a whimsical
it's serious whimsical i can't help but
be both you know it's my life but not
done as a typical biography it's
thoughts flashes free association i open
up if then i have a tape recorder see
and this tape recorder the irony is i'm
inept
mechanically i must tell you this a tape
recorder is my buddy i told you that as
it is
dick nixon he was his buddy and turned
out to be his enemy if it's my buddy
okay at the same time i goof up a lot on
it i pressed the wrong buttons because i
can't drive a car
i can't swim i'm as you can gather i'm
very inept
and never driven
no no i did once in a movie
it was a jane fonda movie it's called
the doll maker
the doll maker was a novel of the south
a very fine novel by harriet springer
harriet
the writer it's about an appalachian
mother of several kids who goes up north
to meet her husband who's got a job the
defense plant during the war they shot
it in chicago it should have been
detroit in chicago the director of the
movie that jane fond was in was dan
patrick who directed stud's place that
program i told you about in fact i
suggested him to be director in new york
or something he became he's a known
movie director now dan peter daniel
petry and he said to jane we're going to
do it in chicago my buddy studs edric is
in it that two lines for a cab driver
two lines
and she's great i know him she said
because we were on platforms together
anti-vietnam you know and so i got two
lines she comes out of the depot and i'm
in the cab with these four little kids
and his little kid and i have a conflict
it's a comic scene two lines and then
dan says to me now you pull out drive
away and we fade out i pull out drive
away and fade out don't you know i never
sat behind a wheel in my life i don't
know what driving a car is like i know a
brake is something you step on or push a
wheel or something you turn i know that
but he's said i forgot that was one of
the standing gags in studs places of all
the people i choose everybody drives
cars old women grandchildren child
molesters everyone drives cars
except him you know what they did
they had to stand in to drive so you
name any actor orson welles or paul
newman
name one actor two lines and had a stand
in some unique in that respect and the
only time i sat behind a wheel very
quickly remembering the whole room boys
remembering what that was the whole room
boys that's the hotel a hall room you
might remember there were halls it was a
man's hotel but it was not a flop house
i mean it was a respectable that is
there was these retired journey genuine
firemen and electricians
invented a plant foreman and so
the
the hall
of the rooms they're the whole room boys
poughkeepsie new york you're next okay
thank you i'm sorry i was going to
finish that no but she's on we'll come
back to it we'll come back to that thank
you my name is anne allen i'm a teacher
at oakwood friends school a quaker prep
school in poughkeepsie new york and i'm
teaching a course on memoir and oral
history and we're using your working and
my question is
given your focus all your life on
talking and recording the lives of
ordinary people
how important is it or would you think
it's important for the individual to
record his or her own life in words not
just in photographs and thank you so
much for your life would that be
wonderful i mean that suggestion is a
wonderful one it is happening
now and then i talk at certain places or
i get letters from people teachers or
mothers or others neighborhoods i say
they're kids
i've equipped for little tape recorders
but i interviewed their grandmothers the
grandfather the old person in the
community
to review your own
could even though even though
will never be published it doesn't
matter it's great if i may suggest it's
great therapy i mean to record your own
life if you can remember and as a result
of what you start thinking about it
i like that idea but especially
young people recording lives of older
people in the community whether it be
grandmother or grandfather or stranger
or a neighbor that i think is important
just that
connection between past and present
either in yourself or with persons
outside so i think that's what i mean
that's [ __ ]
[ __ ] the uh the amnesia
the alzheimer's national alzheimer's
we're talking about if you've just
joined us we are spending three hours
with studs turkle who has written 13
books a 14th on the way
another 35 minutes with more of your
phone calls st petersburg florida go
ahead please
hi it's a great thrill to speak with you
studs i've admired you for a long time
thank you
my question is during the reagan years
was there a loosening
so to speak of the antitrust laws that
quietly occurred and
if that's the case uh have you written
about it or can you recommend any books
to me about it well i think that's crazy
the antitrust laws the sherman and that
trust act that earned in school
is against
special interest which meant
corporations
sherman
today we say special interests are big
labor feminist groups special interests
they're part of america i thought so
there's not which corporation is getting
away with of course there's been a
loosening it's happening now isn't it
with more and more guys the mergers
talking about if it was the anti-trust
violations it's a joke now
we violate that's what i mean by again
no remembrance of past the sherman and i
trust stack is what i recall it meant
standard oil it meant the big outfits
and instead big interest er special
interested now the very groups who are
with their backs to the wall
against the very ones who are special
interests who are called
that's our new religion the free market
you know which don't forget it fell on
its fanny back in the 20s i'm not saying
it's going to fall on his fanny again
but something's got to happen eventually
it won't be a repetition of the crash of
29 but something's going to happen
another one of your books the spectator
this came out when
a few years ago spectator was different
than all the other books the other books
were people like the ordinary so-called
i hate that phrase you know the unknown
people
this dealt with my my feelings as a
plague or as a kid but we had a hotel
after the rooming house was the hotel
near the loop near chicago's loop
and so the press agents in those days
would put posters on the wall of our
lobby these guys never went to theater
but we're close enough to the loops of
depression so i get two free tickets i
was him a play goer at the age of 14. i
go and i saw plays and movies and art
films were around and so
i interviewed a lot of people who are my
heroes buster keaton is in the book talk
about silent film the art of making the
heart of the comedy difference of him
and
uh
tennessee williams interviewed several
times arthur miller
carol channing who is brilliant by the
way she plays the dumb blonde but she's
a brilliant performer in analyzing
people
zero mostel one of the greatest of all
improvisational comics so uh
several thorn like the old british
actress for whom bernard shaw wrote the
play saint joan
and she describes her being an anti
war person and playing a role in the
trojan women the tragedy how being
anti-war in life helped to play this
role of
the mother of the dying people in the
trojan war so uh that is different from
the other books and so the one i
hope to do after the one on death that
i've just finished that is coming out in
november october november which is part
of that trilogy that's called the
spectator the other one's called the
listener and the musical people i've
interviewed
and so here we go
danielle owen from ashland wisconsin has
emailed us mr turquoise
i was born in the same house that your
wife lived and grew up in in ashland
wisconsin then i understand it was
located on third street east it has been
moved quite a few times since then but i
must say i had an incredible childhood
and seriously hope that your wife did
too
avidan she was
how old how old is
the writer uh my uh
ashland wisconsin it's an email well i
wish
she doesn't say how old she was oh if we
round she'd get a tremendous kick out of
that yeah yeah oregon you're next
koos bay oregon you're on book tv
mr turkle yes sir
in your book
um the great war
there was one piece in there
when you spoke with a group captain or a
squadron leader and he was talking about
when he went to his ready room or
something else he felt a little piece of
elation when he heard about the death of
a fellow flyer
you remember this no i don't
do that again i i didn't quite get that
elation
oh
john chardy
john charlie the poet
is describing he was a navigator in a
plane i think and he describes
the selfishness the person feels
and john charlie says and so the sky
died it wasn't me
it's that feeling of combination of
guilt and relations i made it he's
describing the human condition a while
ago a man asked what makes a person so
contradictory and charlie explained that
beautifully it's in that book i forget
what chapter it is and it's john chardy
you're talking was a very good poet by
the way and is describing uh that
feeling
of it's not who
didn't return the flyer it wasn't me i'm
still here and you have this feeling
both of guilt at the same time of
i'm alive
yeah very human
clinton iowa you're next
good afternoon oh good afternoon mr
turkle i i want to compliment you on
your discourse your uh your con
conversation is uh very much out of the
jazz idiom it's wide ranging and very
enjoyable thank you i've got a i've got
a question about iowa's uh favorite son
henry wallace
i wish you would uh
let us know if you've had a interview or
conversation i am glad
mr wallace thank you very much for
asking that question
if i were to name the three great
americans of the century i would say
martin luther king franklin roosevelt
and henry wallace
henry wallace is the most maligned man
in american history of the century henry
wallace now i'm going to start talk as
the new biographies has come out you've
got it's called american dreamer the
story of henry a what is co-authored by
john culver you know john culver the
former senator from iowa it's anna and
john hyde a des moines newspaper guy it
is a wonderful bible i strongly urge
reading of that book henry wallace was
secretary of agriculture for fdr from
1932 to 1940 and those are the glorious
years especially 36 to 40.
now you think of henry wallace you think
of first of all the ever normal granary
and farmers still speak the old ones
that survived henry wallace saving their
lives saving everything thank you henry
wallace the great agronomist hybrid
corners his invention thank you henry i
think of the farm security
administration remember grapes of wrath
and you see the movie at the end henry
fund and jane darwin the joke family
comes to that tent comes that to that
government camp where they're treated
like human beings
that's henry wallace bomb security
administration when it came to certain
collectives they had the sharecroppers
had their own
had their own community
black sharecroppers uneducated little
school they had their own community that
was henry wallace when you saw those
photographs of walker evans and margaret
burke white and dorothea lange and the
farm
farm bravery settlement that was henry
wallace he was the heart and soul of the
new deal
and then he won then came the 1940 he
was then he was vice president for 1940
to 44. he was the vice president who
when he comes to town the vice president
where does he go instead of seeing the
guy's city hall he goes to the public
library to read up on something
and he was vice president in some latin
american country and he's a farmer there
and he's feeding the wheat and he's
coming the farmer says who's that guy is
he a farmer he's no he's the vice
president united states he would go
without betty
henry wallace was so remarkable so
people thought he's going to be the next
president and roosevelt had that in mind
too
so
comes the 1944
campaign
being the kind of guy he is the main
enemies of the party hacks ed kelly of
chicago david lawrence pennsylvania
tom uh frank hague of these are
political taxes you can't win with henry
walks the cold war was beginning and he
was for peace with the soviet union he
was and he had some
pinkos and reds back at him too but the
point is this is henry wallace who
wanted peace in the world mostly
the things he did offended these guys
who would play the old hack game and so
they convinced roosevelt who was ailing
he was ill he was out of it
you can't win with henry wallace he said
the one with the orangutang is running
mate you know but the fact is this is
our boy is harry truman a little hack
from hope from from um
from missouri
who was a
who was the uh
boyer and boy for for tom prendergast
who was indicted the the big uh crooked
politician was the boss of harry and
that's safe with him and so henry
wallace lost and so people formed the
progressive party in 1948 and he ran and
he was maligned as no man was over
benign bubble had ev westbrook peggler
who was a great sports writer became a
nut later on his chief his chief victim
targets with eleanor roosevelt and henry
wallace and he was maligned and
ridiculed and of course lost naturally
big
people voted for truman last minute
but henry wallace truman won because he
took henry wallace's program and that's
what i was suggesting the tribune
article in the last election for gore to
take nader's program truman won because
he had a brilliant adviser clark
clifford and clock slippers said you
don't have to attack henry wallace so
they he did of course or let the other
guy let the ada do it legend one of your
guests arthas lesninger
let them attack him
uh but take his program
anti-poll tax minimum wage national
health take his pr and he did and that's
when given hell harry came into being
and he won with henry henson
john culver and his colleague in this
book explain how henry wallace helped
elect harry truman and i maintain had
gore taken more of nader's program
he'd have been
now unquestionably there'd be no contest
addis cadero california you're next
go ahead caller hello yes i'm calling um
a question for mr turkle
his emphasis is so much on on history
and social commentary and my question is
with so much emphasis in the schools now
on science and mathematics and they're
taking away the arts programs and the
writing programs and all
what i feel are creative programs
how is this going to affect the next
generation being able to identify what's
going on to society and contribute
positive civilizing things that's a good
a very good question of course you're
right the humanities are as essential as
bread and water
the humanities in addition to science
whatever else mathematics uh the hard
science of so-called the humanities the
arts the cult that
enriches our lives it's through these
works we learn to see ourselves through
a pain of goya the spanish pc the
horrors of war disasters of war was a
series and you see that you realize
there was an art critic named alex
elliot describing
a goya and it's a famous one of two guys
are clobbering each other they're in the
water these two fools are clobbering
we're going to kill each other and
there's the sun behind them and if they
don't realize they're both children of
god they're both the same and there's
this wonderful light they're clobbering
each other well
of course that's important
history all of shaykh imagine life
without shakespeare
would we be the poor fruit we'd be
poverty stricken i'm naming let alone
mozart and beethoven and contemporary
composers of course
paintings and dance of course that's
essential to our
and the writings of course
the humanity is so called humanity's not
is not an accidental phrase the humanity
so our humanity will be lessened without
these some would say foibles and frills
and not foibles and frills at all
they're essential
our address is booktv cspan.org you can
also send in your comments about this
and other authors who you may want to
have featured in future programs this is
from mike dean of fort lauderdale who by
the way added to what a number of
viewers have said he has used your book
working in hard times in adult education
classes and his
career counseling aides but his question
is personal he says my father was a
broadcaster in chicago in the 1930s
through the early 1950s his name don
kelly he wrote and produced report
uncensored and one of peabody he
evidently hung out at rick ricardo's and
i have two prints by ricardo that were
given to my dad i'd like to hear more
about who hung out there
about rick ricardo's rick ricardo
he talked about it earlier i think i was
there running to
father john kelly rick ricardo was a
place it was a restaurant right near the
wrigley building
t.k wrigley owned the restaurant later
on ricardo himself bought the building
we're in it's it was one of these open
places especially friday nights friday
night at the bar
everybody was there it just it just
wanted but it's something interesting
the loop that's part of chicago's loop
the loop
even in the 50s
was not welcoming black people
ricardo's was the only place so i ran
into a very distinguished old black
couple
i've seen him for years they never met
him and one day they talked we said does
we know who you are
you know why we come here every year
we've been married 40 years we come here
this was the only place we were welcome
so ricardo was still alive when he told
me this story he said he just got he got
a memorandum from pk wrigley
saying he is disturbed
by ricardo's having certain elements in
his restaurant
he he hopes that will cease so ricardo
back a memo says
i intend to keep on doing what i'm doing
what do you propose to do about it the
last he hurt vk ricky she put up a sign
all men of good will welcome today rick
would have said all men and women of
course of good will welcome and so that
was the place it was great when it
opened
it was first a small place and then the
war then he reopened it and for three
days
it was on the house
everything was on the house it was
fantastic and lord of carlos i miss it
very much but you see i miss it
for another reason i miss my friends i'm
one of the few left microsoft codels and
all right they're all gone among others
and
uh bill mult is no longer around herman
i'm naming now certain people
and
well so
it's not there now but what it is is
this
young people and nothing against them
you know the story to a friend of mine
named charlie andrews charlie wrote the
galloway show and he conceived stud's
place and charlie says do you ever hear
the one about this older guy marriage
this young girl that's pretty good good
marriage two generations the problem is
working out well then one day he meets
the old guy in the corner house we split
up jennifer and i split up how come she
didn't know the songs
and i thought to myself that's it they
don't know the songs meaning of course
it's the metaphor for references so
uh i miss ricardo's of course what what
makes a good martini what makes a what a
good martini you've been referring to
i love martinis but what makes a good
one what makes a good martini touch i
don't know
the gin touch you've removed just a
touch of that a twisted lemon
a martini is a wicked soda drink it's a
naughty drink it's a gala drink a
martini it's different mother drinks now
something holiday about it you know
and marysville kansas you're next with
studs turkey on book tv
hi i'd like to bring you back from
martinis to something teatollers might
like
that is milk
i have uh
a clipping of a distant relative who was
a milk driver wagon
union organizer back when you were about
20 years old studs
and his name was steve sumner and i kind
of wonder if you have ever run into
milk wagon driver union organizers in
chicago
back from that time in the 1930s
steve
sumner some that might have i don't
recall but i may have well run into him
because there's a funny you mentioned it
because the bus driver the other day a
bus driver
i got the card somewhere he'd say his
father was a candidate populist party
candidate for alderman and he this bus
driver his father was a union organizer
way back of bus drivers isn't that
interesting so i may want to run into
steve some at the moment it escapes me
might be a touch of that in me also
possibly not the big a i'm not saying
that but here and now and then i missed
a few names i used to catch pretty well
north andover massachusetts good
afternoon good afternoon thank you for
such a wonderful program
mr turco the lady who spoke to you just
a few minutes ago from california was
calling about creativity and
humanities in schools and i was thinking
along the same exact lines
here in massachusetts we have a new rule
about standardized testing
for the young people before they
graduate from high school or they do not
get their diploma unless they graduate
with this test passed
and i truly feel and i wondered your
opinion
don't you think that for some children
who are really creative versus
uh mechanical
that this standardized test is the worst
thing in the world to try to ask them to
do i'm sure glad you asked that
i when i hear standardized tests my
i'm chilled
what is a standardized test who creates
these tests what's the background of
these people generally it's a proof
white middle class now i give his
standardized tests
i know a little girl went to private
schools she passes high standardized
tests i asked about her gran tell me a
story i said a little girl about you
your grandmother oh yeah
what about your grandmother well she's
in st petersburg she's in retirement
village and she's very nice she sent me
christmas gifts every year so here's a
little black kid and they get on your
jukebox they're horsing around and i got
the microphone i'm seeing somebody
tell me about st tell me your story
about what about your auntie cruz auntie
mean his grandmothers and he tells the
story
and it's funny and it's wonderful
he flunks the s.a.t
now who is the brighter of the two i'm
not saying he's more bright than she is
but all the joy and the learning in this
kid the storytelling oral history see
he's telling the story it's witty it's
funny about his grandmother and him how
she believes she tells a story about the
man walked with his head on his arm like
anne boleyn you know
but he and and i know she's fooling
around she's kidding but i hear her
laughing quiet in the dark there as you
tell that story to me she knows i know
she's kidding but as he tells a story
he's a wonderful storyteller now she
didn't know anything
well she sent me nice gifts she passes
big so that's what standardized test is
all about to me it's this phony is a
three dollar bill when it comes to
testing intelligence hillsborough oregon
you're next yes um studs i was brought
up in chicago and um you know was a
nurse um working in all neighborhoods um
met many people that were from all races
and i feel that what's lacking a lot of
times are
people looking in their eyes of the
other person and seeing
their sense of humor their person
and i wondered um with all the people
that you've met in your life
what do you think about when you first
meet someone and how can we change how
people look at everyone that they meet
in their life and make a better
difference to the world thanks caller
and let me just follow up on that
because we have a related email from a
viewer in ohio don stumpf who who asked
the question how his living in chicago
influenced your writing
well without chicago i'd be dead chicago
to me is
one of him age of eight i was an
asthmatic child i lost the asthma coming
to chicago i was maintaining that fair
wind blowing for stockyards and
somebody's there came we were near it
were west side but within the on a
summer night that wind would build the
stock i think that cured my asthma
but i love chicago because it's the
archetypal american city to me it's
city of hands
you know hand is an old-fashioned word
for 50 hands wanted you know george and
lenny and mice and men answer a call of
the san francisco schedule 100 hands
wanted on this ranch so she got city of
hands
so the skyscraper came out of chicago
louis sullivan
frank lloyd wright
and that steel and so chicago was the
athens
of architecture you know
all architects come to chicago to see
the work of these geniuses
and so but chicago to me is
jane addams as well as al capone as well
as big bill thompson as well as john
peter although
it's this announce nelson aldrin's theme
the two chicagos and uh it's godhead as
janus janus the roman god two faces
two cutters so-called and the two others
and so that's chicago forever
jackson wyoming you're next
there good afternoon hello hello
okay
if you remember remember me or not i i
was one of the old
uh habituates of the place the ecology
complexes
on norse world streets the college of
complexes yeah slim brandage
that was his name slim brendage he ran
it byron flynn
the college of complex is a throwback to
the old wobbly day wobbly's iww and the
hobo college just political hobo and
this guy slim brendan's ran this
everybody spoke there soapbox wacky but
it was very exciting and so
he's no longer around you know as you
can guess he died now slim died
and he was he was the last of the deans
that scott is a place called bug house
square
i love bug house square buck house
square is like hyde park in london you
know and uh bike house square is no
longer every year there's a celebration
so i go to that but it's gone you see
with tv
with uh the whole changes taking place
uh
computer
the speech the human voice see i love
the sound vox humana the sound of the
human voice
less and less of the human voice
obviously when you make a telephone call
if you get a human voice i hear someone
answering you might say oh thank god
you're human
and it's so and so that's rare of course
because what you when you call some out
of business especially
oh man here comes the ordeal
we'll go on to baltimore maryland you're
next on book tv
uh yeah hello i'm with you yeah
yeah yeah uh yeah i've finished uh that
book the spectator
when you're in baltimore i purchased it
and uh i met you you signed my book at
the store there
and you mentioned in the book about
the l l some
lounge over on
lasalle street actually was the h h
lounge with macy bear
and you and you mentioned in the book
and you uh actually told me one well we
met uh at the store that he was killed i
didn't know he was murdered you know who
was that oh musher bear
yeah yeah he was murdered in fact mike
royko had a very funny it was kind of
funny how to come about that much bear
well i i have to explain that whole
thing
there was a restaurant near the studio
where wfmt was on lasalle street
illinois it was frequented by judges by
crooks
by thieves by lawyers and they all knew
one another the line of demarcation was
the narrow one
and so mike wrote some very funny
columns about that and so this guy named
maesha bear was sort of involved with
things i hijacked a truck of this too
and he's supposed to be in juliet
you see he's supposed to be in prison
but he's behind the counter and i'm this
innocent college boy and i'm then and
the waitress name is dorothy and dorothy
i said dorothy as i get i have my salmon
salad sandwich and a cup of coffee the
lunch you know and i said dorothy
there's almost a bear there uh and she's
i beg your pardon the moisture bag
behind her is he supposed to be in
do you want pickle with that
do you want dessert i said no no i'm but
i'm thinking about you
you want some sugar on your coffee you
know and then she's thinking to herself
who is a stupid kid none of his business
probably he had a clout somewhere you
see so he's out he's serving and so
nothing's wrong so i love that place
another one of your books my american
century
yeah
that's sort of an ant quasi anthology i
chose certain ones from the different
books to put in it left out of course a
lot of them
but uh that's sort of an anthology
sort of
hopewell junction new york okay next
call
another five or six warnings this is
pretty good it's good time it's gone
like a house of fire we'll go another
three years get warmed up
go ahead caller
uh hello studs uh
i really believe that you're a national
treasure and uh
i really hope that your work uh
is uh followed up on and i was wondering
uh who you believe is that's working
today is uh is following your footsteps
would you think is closest to you in
uh sympathy and
position
there are some you mean
those following in my footsteps you say
yes well i think there are a number of
young people who are doing books at the
moment there are a number of young
who i like very much at the moment names
escape me but
i hope so
and i get this question often asked a
lot of the fault is mine for not having
i work by myself as you gather work
haphazardly
as you also gather thus far where the
hours are nearly up that it's been an
accretion of accidents and so i often
work by myself except for the
transcriber and as a result of which
i've had no young
adjutant you know with me and so i feel
bad about that except a lot of people
kid young guys and women
men and women who are doing this work
and i'm happy to know that so it'll go
on of course and we'll go on to santa
monica california with studs circle
hey mr turco how goes it
i hear ya
excellent listen uh
in my travels around the past 40 years i
sat in san francisco and talked with the
man who ran the the unions at the docks
i used to sit in a coffee house and just
talk with him
and uh i think he's the man that climbed
the nazi flagpole on that ship in new
york harbor that you wrote about in the
great in the in the good war
and uh i was wondering if that was big
bill thompson or do you remember the
name of that guy he also fought in the
spanish civil war and could you talk
about him bill bailey
bill bailey
haley that's it yeah he was fantastic
figure bill bailey in fact uh he was in
a couple of movies i think chris chris
jefferson had him bill bailey is a
spanish civil war veteran he also was in
a merchant marines
and he climbed up their flag and de
bremen was a nazi ship there at the time
laguardia was mayor of new york and he
and uh
he was very funny and wonderful
he died some years ago
bill bailey was his name very colorful
and we haven't talked with the spanish
civil war it's another aspect
let me just go back to uh peggy terry
was one of the people that you know
peggy terry one of the one of the
individuals
terry is one of my very favorites
peggy terry appears in about three or
four books she's the appalachian woman
from well ozaki and she's from paducah
western kentucky and peggy had little
education
but peggy is so eloquent and so rich
he's in the new book too
and peggy speaks of
the good war
i got a job also hard times peggy has a
way of talking and i'm so poetic so
lyrical and she says when i read grapes
of wrath she read grapes of remember she
had fifth grade red grapes i never felt
so proud of being what i was and when
until i read grapes of wrath
but peggy is well you have a point into
something well i was you wrote by the
end of the war someone like peggy is
what my books are all about she talks
about the beautiful celebrations when
the war ended they were selling
cigarettes in paducah up until that hour
you could have bought a pack of
cigarettes for love or money kirchoff's
bakery was giving away free loaves of
bread everybody was downtown in the
pouring rain we were dancing we were so
happy that night my husband and i came
home we went out with a gang of friends
and got drunk yeah oh and peggy of
course just everything she said was came
out poetically
peggy's the one i should tell took part
in a civil right she was a racist
originally a father was a clansman
originally and and peggy at the same
time he was a wonderful guy this is
crazy this is what the man asked about
earlier about the contradictions and
people what shakespeare does so well
well peggy
one day saw martin montgomery alabama
she's martin luther king uh and when
there he is with other white women there
he is and a couple of guys beat him up
i just that's funny
several guys beat him up
bloody guy it is we used to think uh two
two against one or five against one is
[ __ ] fun meaning they do that they
those other people do that here they
said to martin and that changed around
she became a civil rights advocate and
she was arrested several demonstrations
and she speak an operation push
jesse jackson's group for overwhelming
black audience and just here i am people
ask me my friend said what are you doing
with those people doing that and you
know you're in jail
she's where else could poor white trash
like me meet a nobel prize laureate dr
king but here in prison you know what
happened that audience just went crazy
black audience they went they were
shouting and cheering for five minutes
kept going and going and going hey man
she just moved them so much with that
one comment well that's peggy of course
well
our last call from new york city
good afternoon yes hi uh mr turkle my
name is jeff shirt and i'm calling from
new york city very nice to have you on
tv show here today thank you i've been
quite fascinated with the american dream
i'm a painter and i've been questioning
what it is to be an american since
living in sweden
if this is such a great country
and the true mark of a great society is
reflected in its art
why is this country so brutal in how it
treats its artists and i've begun to
realize that stripes don't stand for
freedom
well of course that's
that's the big one you see you were in
sweden of course sweden we know has
associated sweden uh the
middle class the others don't object to
paying taxes
that is for health education and welfare
it's part of what they consider
civilized civil behavior we talked about
affirmative civility way back in sweden
and it's practiced a great extent you
see we have got to learn certain
fundamentals about ourselves we remember
now the very nature
of the news we get and i will end with
this i found that the american ordinary
person is intelligent that doesn't mean
not ignorant to certain things but
ignorant not fall i mean not knowing
certain things because we know who run
the means of communication that's why it
involves community
action that's why it involves community
back and forth and a person the
individual will end with this i like to
quote einstein because nobody dares to
contradict you it's like einstein
einstein says people think that interest
in the community will take away
individual liberty the contrary is the
case it makes you stronger just as a
union in union there is strength in
community there is strength and so the
individual becomes more and more of a
person and suddenly you realize if he
says something takes him for serious he
counts to count it's terribly important
and we feel we don't count the way it is
today and to count is to actually take
part these people saying studs how come
you're 88 yes because i'm interested
curiosity
maybe that's maybe that's the medicine
i've been taking all my life i don't
know maybe so that's what it's about
really when you're interested in that
other
it makes you stronger
your individuality all the stronger too
and not a cipher
we have tried to focus on each of your
13 books the 14th one is coming out when
it's come out in
october or december that's the one
called
one called uh
will the circle be unbroken about death
but it's the liveliest book i've ever
written and i hope people
get to see that and read it and finally
what's your lesson on life what my what
lesson on life
you've learned over the years
what's my lesson
to live
show no casey said it way back
for boy girl have the courage to bring
to live
to live means what to live not just you
don't live in a vacuum we live in a
world of others to live in that world
not to sacrifice i don't mean to give
things up i got my two martinis a day
and two pretty good cigars a day too but
to
be curious about the world and what's
happening elsewhere and that makes your
life i think all the richer
me hopefully longer so we'll see
this has been great you mean three hours
again
well we just get warmed up yeah that's
terrible thank you very much thank you
very much you've been very good and
everybody who called thank you now i'm
gonna put my hearing aid back on
you've been watching in depth with studs
turkle pulitzer prize-winning author of
the good war and oral history of world
war ii race how blacks and whites think
and feel about the american obsession
and talking to myself a memoir of my
times
this program will re-air in its entirety
tonight at midnight eastern 9 pm pacific
coming up in may our in-depth guest